bandai namco
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
give it up for your champion
is this not some good ass tekken ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to tekken
online challenge 2021 philippines and
east asia online masters i am kid and
with me man i am honored to be sharing
the mic with the man himself rip rip
how's it going my man
i am doing pretty good excited to be
here of course the philippines one of
the one of my favorite regions of world
protect but we also got some extra
countries in here right it's also east
asia involved in this tournament uh we
are winding our way down this top eight
it's gonna be a great night full of top
competitors you know we already know
some of the players that have qualified
into this top eight so far so i'm really
excited there's some names though you
guys are already familiar with uh you
know i'm a law player you're a lot
player we got a former law player in the
top eight already in ak uh you know it
sounds like a good night already to me
yeah it does sound like it you know not
only uh not only are there gonna be a
lot of exciting matches we also do have
a lot of exciting players to look out
for especially one unknown name that we
have in the top eight right now it is
t-rex who beat gold standard now if you
guys don't know who gold standard is and
this one's for rip also gold standard is
the top lego player here in the
philippines he just got sent to losers
yeah that's crazy right i mean and
that's the thing obviously you are the
resident expert in the region you know
i'm going to be leaning heavily on you
to fill me in all the player lord
because i'm not gonna know most of it uh
but i do know that we got some heavy
hitters out here so go standing down and
lose a bracket t-rex the unknown that we
don't know about yet he's gonna be
someone that we do see throughout the
tournament since he's on the winner's
side of the top eight uh but of course
guys the technology is brought to you by
astro the official headset and mix amp
of the tekken online challenge
uh but yeah this should this should be a
crazy night you know i know last time i
was watching you here at the tekken
online challenge in the philippines
region it was you and posh and you guys
were holding it down what felt like two
days for a tournament with one
continuous stream you know it was it was
beautiful you guys did a great job so
i'm here for the long haul you know i'm
ready i'm ready for the entire night i
took a nap i'm prepared we're gonna have
a fun night out here
you know i i had some trouble sleeping
myself because i'm like oh my goodness
what if what if the this this is this
again or what if it's not again you know
uh but things have been quite better
things have been way better since you
know uh second online challenge 2020.
and the fact is you know people are
connecting a lot easier now and yeah i'm
so excited to uh did you see the matches
rip what are you looking forward to the
most
i'm just trying to see some good ass
tekken you know like i mean you said all
that about connecting max i just started
knocking on wood because i was like all
right i hope this pulls through you know
things have been a lot better here yes
yes yes knocking on the wood out here uh
but yeah there's a lot of players and
obviously these are big opportunities
for them to finally crack in to this top
eight but of course you guys are seeing
on your screen right now these are the
standings right this is a mattress event
they're trying to get to the regional
finals these are points that they've
accumulated so far you see jules sitting
out here a hundred points ak with 70.
titan thor third place 45 gold standard
with 10 we just mentioned maru jean
japon j i see how do you say that is
that jic
yeah
that's a jig there you go boom easy so
easy that's the topic currently but
they're going to get their points from
this event which they're trying to get
to the regional finals right so that's
the goal here like i think i think this
event of the match event there's a
couple thousand dollars online regional
finals is like triple that so a lot of
potential here for these players
assuming they make that regional finals
yeah that's right and um you know i do
recommend keeping your eyes on jewels
and ak because these guys have been
going at it especially in other
tournaments also so it's really gonna be
exciting to see because these two right
now undisputedly are the best in the
philippines even though a lot of a lot
of people say that you know there there
isn't a best in the philippines right
now i do have to mention these two names
jules and aka and you know a little bit
of a funny story titan thor he's we saw
him like around uh third right if i
remember correctly third uh yeah he went
into yeah he went into the
a certain tournament
and he was making waves in the top eight
and he went under the name of dolan one
two three four five now nobody ever
found out who this guy was and it just
so happened it was titan thor and he's a
well-known name in the community because
he he's got these wacky setups for for
fang he's a fan user he key charges he'd
rather key charge than do a full combo
at the wall this guy is really
interesting and he's in this tournament
yeah he's i see him right now he's still
in the loser bracket he's working his
way up to the top eight uh gonna be a
little bit of a hard path he's got three
matches and then he's gotta take out
maru to qualify into that top eight
losing side of things so you know when
we get there hopefully you'll still be
around because that sounds pretty
exciting anyone who's throwing out key
charges mid-match and using it as part
of their strategy not just the pop off
i'm down i'm down i don't see some count
rates
oh yeah for sure and not only was he the
the the one just starting the the key
charge setups it's been a cakey's been
doing that a lot also uh whenever he'd
re whenever he'd carry his opponent to
the wall he
rather than going for a full welcome key
charge into whatever he wants to do
because he's ak right crazy crazy player
you know i'm sure you know this because
he does play law as well
oh yeah i mean i mean when i think of ak
i think it's like a player who's just
committed to doing something you don't
expect them to do like when he saw him
using a [ __ ] before he did like
literally like ten down fours and i was
like he's not gonna do another one like
eight of them in a row no way nine of us
why not
you know he's just that kind of a player
same thing with like the slide mixed up
or anything so ensuring that he's the
kind of player who's also bringing out
key charge into his gameplay sounds
pretty exciting again the way you just
describe it there as using key chart
setup at the wall
like you got me thinking i'm like is
that a good idea like maybe i should
just avoid a wall combo turn on a key
charge with law and go for a 50 50.
you're like give me new thoughts and
process to think about here
[Music]
you know it's it's it's extra mental
mix-up you know when coming into play
because titan thor he's well he's very
well known for that and he posts a lot
of highlights on his channel as well so
uh you know if you guys want to check
that out
i do recommend it it's pretty funny to
watch and you know that's one thing
right the no mix-up mix-up like uh
shaheen and the law they got those
slides and then we got the mishimas with
the with the hell sweeps and elsewhere
it's pretty exciting to yeah it's pretty
exciting to see
what's in store for us here because you
know in a tournament anything can happen
and
i'm sure you you can you can say that as
well
oh yeah in a tournament setting you
don't know what players are going to do
and i feel like sometimes when you play
unorthodox that's kind of the best way
to play the tournament especially
against a player that knows your style
right you bring something new to the tip
you're like yeah i'm going to do this
five times because you've never seen me
do it five times in a row and that's why
it's gonna work this time
uh but of course you know guys there are
a ton of players out here uh and we're
winding our way down to the top here
right so right now we're setting up for
a match uh i do have the names and it's
gonna be hong kong versus the
philippines that's gonna be interesting
uh because obviously as we mentioned you
know this is not just the philippines
right uh of course the majority of
players in it so far qualify for top
eight are for the philippines it seems
like but there are other copies hong
kong trying to get in here as well uh
we'll see the players in just a second
but are there any other players in this
in this bracket that are left standing
that you think we should keep an eye on
that maybe aren't as well known
let me go ahead and check here there's a
guy here called uh
jason or his his name is spelled as js5n
he's a jaguar main but recently been
branching out to other characters like
geese and some and probably uh probably
some akuma as well but this guy
really really good he's very easy he's a
he's a cool guy he just is a cool guy
he's a cool guy
yeah
okay
would you say jaguar do you mean king or
armor kick i'm assuming you mean armor
king both
multiple oh so when you say jaguar
you're like both jaguars got it okay wow
okay i'm learning today you know jaguar
main either one huh uh so you said them
or either geese or what's the other
character akuma
okay so he went full 2d and jaguar
that's what i'm hearing well all right
he sounds he sounds kind of cool you
know i don't know
the 2d part kind of takes it down a
notch personally for me you know but the
jaguar part that's pretty cool
yeah and you know taking a look at the
other brackets here we do have also
sidestep plans now we did discuss this a
bit upstream sidestep lance is known as
the lee chow lawn in the philippines
he's probably the best lee
uh best lee right now and we don't see a
lot of lee challan at all because a lot
of people think he's a bad character now
rip i want to know what you think about
the chao line
yeah you know lee
i think has always been a very annoying
character to deal with i feel like since
tekken tag 2 that character has gotten
even safer and harder to approach uh you
know back four is just like this cover
all kind of strategy and you know if you
have a life lead with lee and you just
play that turtle strat that feel it can
be super effective uh you know as far as
like where does lee stand the tearless i
don't feel like we've had a lead player
really break out in tournament you know
and that's hard to say whether it's the
players holding it back or the character
holding it back right uh you never
really know in those kind of situations
uh but i think the character is still
very strong i think it's possible for a
lead player to get done i just think
that we haven't seen one yet uh you know
in the us at least fighting gem was our
top lead player for a long time you know
he doesn't really enter tournaments as
much but what he did come out this two i
believe was summer jam last year or the
year before man i'm losing track of
yours he got top three in that
tournament you know and it was it was
pretty cool to see like you know we
haven't seen him around no one sees leaf
placing it high in these like bigger
tournaments and he put lee on top either
so i think the character is still got a
lot of potential we just haven't seen a
tap yet
yeah and going by your point as well you
know it's it's pretty difficult to bring
lee to a very high level especially when
it comes to tournaments like this right
but sidestep lance
he was such a high performing player
in previous tournaments that you know it
makes people think huh is lee actually
secretly top tier and people just
haven't figured out you know the
potential of the cat of that character
so it's really exciting to see also and
you know uh straying a bit away from
sidestep plans there's one uh player
here in the loser bracket for pool
number one that's rgn
now rgn is in akuma main
really really young also and he's been
showing uh he's been showing that he can
go toe-to-toe against the top players
here in the philippines so uh definitely
something to look forward to
rjn akuma player yeah i'm looking at him
now he's a loser semis just took out my
event it looks like uh waiting for the
winner of either hapon or georgie uh so
upon has been on you know this path of
terror throughout the loser bracket here
today uh something very early who sent
upon to losers actually
very good that's a guy
that's a guy from what's georgie s
georgie yeah georgie is
uh
a gigas player uh from cebu i think i
think he's representing uh representing
tagayan de oro uh which is in vindan now
different part of the philippines here
and
yeah you said all those words that my
brain just went out of me
but you know that doesn't matter that
much all i all we know is that this guy
is pretty damn good
for us george he's pretty
is coming into streams and then says um
request digas i i want you to play yes
this guy is a gigas enthusiast i'm not
kidding all right dude i think giggis
has a lot of potential we were talking
slightly earlier as well you know gigas
i feel like has a lot of good reputation
in asia in general right especially if
you watch like the weekly icfc
tournaments i feel like there's always a
gigas around there uh in in europe even
to have one but in north america we
don't really have a gig is really
putting in work and you know putting
stuff on the map out there but that says
georgie hop on that is a run back that's
a double jeopardy situation uh hapon
could be facing elimination here this is
the guy that you know sent the loser
back in the first place uh kind of a
dangerous platform and as i mentioned
happens being like six people lose
bracket just to get back to ss georgie
and even if he gets passed or there's
still two more people to make it to the
top eight it's not not an easy fact at
all
it's a it's a tough road and i watched
georgie's stream earlier when he fought
japan it was of course gigas versus
geese so
um
hapon isn't exactly known for his uh for
his geese he's known as the eddie of the
philippines also because he's the best
eddie in the philippines and now we have
a match here that sidestep plans we were
talking about him earlier versus who is
this this is eerie
eerie from hong kong here we go
exactly all right all right
this one should be interesting so we
want to see you this is the lead that
you said has like potential to be really
good right but oh my goodness decide
that pop kick from eerie okay that's how
you feel
all right we're going downstairs also
there's gonna be big damage for eerie no
he misses the last part of the combo
good duck
fantastic duck guess lots another floor
gone immediately we've lost two floors
in just 25 seconds
nice side step on the wake up too that's
perfect
sidestep right you know just be patient
there
yeah besides the right block
of kicks
yep so good nice block on the slide and
we're in the basement that was a really
quick path to the basement
[Music]
oh no
all right unfortunate ending for you
right there sidestep last counter hit
back forth and converts to a combo are
we gonna see a wall here they ask me you
will
wow
i travel aggression back to the wall
fury is so good both players at rage
good block on the mid but eerie
interrupts with a down forward one
series and he's on two rounds against
side step friends
yeah cyto blast in a bit of trouble in
that situation like he had the spring
kick
but just got caught back the wall wasn't
really cautious to move away from it
again from eerie so good sidestep lance
up against the wall half elf hiri tries
to go for another wall mount here
decides to last smallest of life leads
got good positioning here on the stage
back to wall knight down jab interrupter
from eerie
dang good stuff smart choice and you
know seismic lance
really had trouble maintaining his
likelihood situations there and also
looks like maybe there's a little bit of
character unfamiliarity right
miguel i feel like is a character that
we don't really have a ton of experience
against in general uh so i mean i don't
know if you guys have any big miguel
players out of the philippines
uh but that could always be a major
cause for concern right because miguel
is one of those players that is
definitely underrepresented uh but also
one of the strongest players or
characters in the game that people
aren't really talking about
yeah for sure it's just that he he just
doesn't have that you know uh the same
star power that you know uh leroy lydia
falconram has is miguel's just standing
in the corner waiting for someone to
talk to him that's the type of character
miguel is and uh
funny story about miguel's actually um
in a previous tournament we've seen it
was dojin using miguel and he's been
using miguel for days and we know
dojin is a multi-character specialist
and
this
he was up against this player
and he killed him with hatchet kicks
seven times seven straight heads
and he never bothered to block it's the
mental mix-up it's the mental
game do it again it's the classic saying
you know do it again hatch kick is one
of those moves all right where the mix
up behind it is so strong that sometimes
you know if you can't react you can't
you have to block it uh and honestly
it's it feels like one of those moves
but you can kind of react to it like
just a tiny bit but
you're gonna eat like seven in a row
sometimes it just happens
yeah it's always the thought he's not
gonna do it again he said it's it's it's
similar it's all the same to you know
it's all the same to hell sweeps and
stuff i'd rather not get hit by a big
mid that launches me i'd rather eat the
i'd rather eat the low mix up but you
know eventually you're gonna have to to
block the low because you're gonna get
killed by it
of course
all right here we go game two switching
up mission with dojo incoming round one
good ole miguel let's see
let's see if seistep lance
can get on the board here
he was around
yeah
that string from miguel down four three
two that's actually really good it's a
mid mid so you know you can't i hate
that it looks like a high yeah
it should be a high everyone else has a
high one you know come on man yeah
got him back forward that's the answer
yeah i mean it's not necessarily i said
it's the answer but really it's like the
do everything move you
know right so this is where sidestep
lands shines where he has the life lead
and he's going to continue having that
light lead until he puts his opponent at
rage good sights that good block oh
yeah i mean that was such good awareness
there for the combo and everything
knowing that the wall is right beside it
uh erie is looking really sharp right
now this is not
a good position for sidestep left it
feels like every time he feels like he
has a small edge he's able to bring him
back and steal it away from him
yeah right now it looks like sasha plans
he is just fishing
[Music]
oh
good sidewalk that's the way you want to
walk miguel you want to go left and he's
done a good job of it
uh but unfortunately you know this is
what's been happening oh no
i mean the good news is he left him out
of rage
it's all fine it's all planned you know
what let's let's believe in sidestep
fence here oh here we go slide mix-ups
the first one that we've seen hit today
yeah i want to see more slides as a lot
player more slides
gonna connect to the wall oh misses the
last hit that's unfortunate but he does
leave him outside of rage 2 eerie has
the potential for come back here up
against the wall
oh no
he got a clip
okay just be careful
do you try to step left down jab into up
the savage make some beautiful beautiful
scary but good it was a very
yeah scary bet for sidestep plans the
you know the back three would have
crushed the down job so good decision
making wow
oh he had the part three okay okay the
pickup nice
it's so hard to do especially when it's
online i gotta
you gotta give props to this guy here we
equal health can he get to come back in
no he should just lost that foreign
converted
opportunity for erie to make a crazy
comeback here
oh no
we saw him do it at the last game but
this time he clipped it good block oh
but no proper finish
okay okay
here we go get to the wall here get the
combo and this has been the story right
lively precisely lance but that area
with the comebacks
let's see if you can hold on to this one
and close out the game and tie things up
oh there it is again that string spin is
killing down three
the
pickups
not like this get away from the wall oh
my gosh
all right my heart stopped for a quick
second right there but you know sidestep
land still got it
a little bit of pressure there not bad
size of glass you know he's shaking a
little bit in his boots right there but
tied up now we're tied up one game a
piece here sidestep lands uh you know it
seems like he's making some adjustments
here and really it just comes down to
when he's got the lively and how he's
going to maintain it because erie has
been so good at bringing it back every
single time right and you know the the
one drop he had that would left him out
of rage kind of saved him but then it
didn't matter right eerie stole that
round anyway uh but there's been a lot
of great adjustments in terms of dealing
with the savage mix-up uh and now the
questions become what happens in game
three right like you see the players
adjusting like oh is he using
soundtracks here which one he's going
for it's gonna be the low kick yes it is
i'm gonna start down jabbing as you
mentioned back he might come out so a
lot of stuff on table a lot of mind
gives happen between the players you
know at this level and we just got to
see how it plays out in game three in a
second
and you know that went really good for
saison plans until it didn't
because uh
you know he had he had he had a few
options to
to just shut down those savage mix-ups
like the down jab right but if
it didn't work out for him and that in
that round we saw last time and you know
he's gonna have to mix up a few
decisions here is does he want to go
down job or does he want to go for a
check with a downfard one but the risk
of that is he might get you know he
might get interrupted with the fastest
uh savage dance savage stance move which
is savage one i think i believe
i hate miguel you tell me
but you know the question mark here
it's all gonna come down to this third
game right who's moving on in the
bracket
is this one a loser bracket i think it
is right fight
yes it is i think so i yeah i think it
is yeah
yeah this is the get to loser final of
the pool here man he's been landing a
lot of these counter hit down threes
and he does get the balcony sometimes
that corner you get stuck
this is a
massively oh my goodness he got the
right punishing but the range on the
acid rain was not enough sidestepped
still had the idea so guess the round
anyway
yeah i think he wanted forward four
three but he didn't get the full input
in time right
wow right over the top
oh inside the place he's he's looking
like he's in a groove right now
yeah my goodness theory trying to look
for the openings on aggression but he
can't find anything he's just one hit
away sidestep lance has a massive life
lead
this is where he's been messing up
though
oh my god 10 string
this is where he's been messing up
though
what the combo bro
oh my god he just did it he just did it
sidestep lance set point right now
you think a art would have killed i
don't know man
i i mean it probably would have done
better than the combo he did put it that
way
yeah that's that's so true
though has him up against the breakable
wall ooh tray
[Music]
yeah eerie's looking a little shook
right now
[Music]
dude
all right that should tie things up here
the wall gets in the way
save the life for a second
round but it's not over yet you know
ears you're making rounds come back he's
trying to make the full three round come
back
that was so weird because the wall
should have broken
yeah that's odd
it's still
slow for both of these guys
yeah
lance is looking really comfortable now
though like even when he's behind here
he's looking much more comfortable than
you look at that first game bounce
hold the mix down three wall pressure
beautiful side step lance two to one
over eerie eliminates erie from the
tournament nice try uh philippines
moving on to the losers final here i
believe this was pool number four
uh that we had here so one more match
and size of lance could be in that top
eight but his next opponent would have
to be gold standard
it looked a bit shaky for side still
plants in the especially in that
first game excuse me yeah in that first
game but you know he adjusted pretty
well that's that's really good for him
and now erie is eliminated from this
tournament you have to fight gold
standard again another tough opponent to
fight against because these guys have
been fighting each other since like what
uh
since a few months ago
and you know i want to see how much
sidestep plans has improved here
yeah the thing is in this tournament
they already met gold standard already
sent sidesteplands to the loser bracket
in the start it was 2-0 so i'm looking
at the bracket correctly here uh so size
of lance has an opportunity and you know
he might be one of these players i mean
you tell me if i'm wrong here but maybe
he's one of these players who has a
little bit of a slow start and the
longer the set goes he gets more data
and does better uh because that's what i
saw in that one set that i just got to
watch with him and erie in a second ago
uh but as you mentioned you know
sometimes we're playing players for
months and months you know they get to
run in you completely lose it bracket
comes though they're coming off a loss
their brand is in the same place they
were before uh you're coming off a win
you know sometimes that momentum is all
you need uh to turn things around to
lose a bracket
and that actually makes a lot of sense
because you know uh based on what
sidestep lance has been showing us in
the past few months in in many different
tournaments also he's he's known to have
like shaky starts he normally loses game
one and then downloads in game two and
then absolutely dominates in game three
and
part of me says that's kind of a big
strength for him because you know uh
downloading your your downloading your
opponent isn't as easy as you think so
anyone out there who's watching it it is
not easy it takes a lot of brain power
your brain juice
for for yourself to function
exactly yeah you need the brain juice
man uh but yeah i think myself as a
player you know back when i used to
compete regularly uh that was always my
problem i felt like where i would lose
the first game but
at the time even though i lost the first
game i would be super comfortable
because i knew exactly what i had to
change and i was very comfortable the
rest of the set so even to this day like
losing one game of the tournament i have
the mentality of you know it's only one
game if you want to win the set you got
to win two and i have all the
information that i have now to beat you
for the rest of the set so i'm very
comfortable losing the first game
nowadays as well unless it's like really
close to someone harder and more
difficult then you don't lose ever he's
like let's get this over with i don't
want to deal with this guy tomorrow run
out of brain juice
uh but i believe the next match that we
have coming up here is actually going to
be uh the player you're hyping up with
that fang weight titan thor
uh going up against uh how do we say
this jace is it jason jason jace fiven
it's jason jason jason
i was close-ish
uh yeah that should be the next matchup
and
rubbing by the characters again get this
because we know time thor is probably
the fang way right
uh but jasmine
character wise jason's a jaguar man yeah
jaguar main that's right oh he's a
jaguar the two army king yeah was that
him yeah was he also the 2d guy was that
someone else okay okay all right i'm
hoping for the jaguars then
what do you think about fang right now
in the game i feel like fang you know he
got these buffs and at least in n a
we're seeing a lot of uh fan players
doing a lot better than they have in the
past
i i think frank's really good it's just
he's just underrepresented you know i'm
uh watching
watching the n a scene uh you know
especially joey fury joyful has been on
making waves also nashi
pretty doing pretty well uh with the
character and not a lot that you see
here in the philippines so i'm really
excited to see titan thor show us the
potential of this characters because um
let's be real okay let's let's be real
here uh feng isn't exactly
uh when you're a new player feng doesn't
look like that type of character that
you would pick you picked like the
coolest character depending on you know
depending on who you are right are you
are you saying fang doesn't look cool is
that what i'm hearing
don't you instigate me like this
you said it not me bro
you said hey when you're a new player
you're not looking at fang you're
looking at the cool characters
who is this who's the cool character in
your eyes dad okay well but then who is
it when you look at the garage but who's
the who's the cool character to you
there's only one right now looks cool
devil jim
that guy he's got like the bandages
everywhere okay now we're talking there
we go see okay that was the edge i was
looking for yeah
you're right mention law you're right
yeah i'm sure you don't even play the
character right
exactly law is amazing um but no yeah i
think fang actually the reason i brought
that up is because when fan came out i
thought he looked super cool when he was
introduced yeah like in tekken 5 i
remember uh seeing the character and i'm
like dude this guy like at the time i
was the law and paul main and feng
looked like the combination he looked
like he was going to be
that character the fusion of law and
paul into one character right because
back then law was a skinny guy right
like when you look at tekken 7 law law
is ripped now right he shred he's going
to gym non-stop since tekken 5. but at
the time tekken 5 he was just a skinny
little dude and paul was all big and the
fan came out you're like boom there you
have it you know chinese martial arts
plus a body like paul fades we can hit
people real hard like a dead fist that's
what i thought the character was going
to be yeah so i used them quite a bit
but you know it was really just ended up
being a very poke heavy character
and i think that because of that i think
that he's still a very strong character
especially now
the problem is you know in this game you
also need other tools but fans rage
drive is one of the best in the game i
feel like you know i feel like as soon
as that rage drive activates it's going
through whatever else was on the screen
you know you're like oh i'm blue i'm
powering through i don't care
so i i think fang is very very good
right now and definitely as you
mentioned underrepresented
yeah it's it's like it's like his rage
arts got like iframes or something but
you know the reason why exactly uh the
reason why the reason why i said fang
isn't the isn't much of a like uh cool
character as perceived by the players
here in the philippines is because he
isn't exactly the first choice because
when you see characters like devil jin
or paul with a wacky hair thing feng
looks average compared to the other
characters you know you know what i mean
what about the eyebrows bro he's got
like four eyebrows her eyebrow you know
i mean that's pretty cool right
i mean paul has wacky airfare he's got
four eyebrows
kind of cool man i don't know
yeah um but i can see your point uh and
you know when i when i think about fang
right
people play as a very poke heavy
character now but if you go back to when
the characters introduced you would see
a lot more forward two one two and it
was kind of like this counter hit uh
fishing tool right uh back one four two
one two
uh even down four two two right like
which wasn't a counter tool but it's
just a very good tool in general
uh those tools aren't really the core of
fang way anymore uh and i feel like
they're still good though they just
haven't uh
really been abused by the fan players
and now you mentioned titanfall like
using these key charges i'm really
curious if he goes for that four two one
two because i have not seen fan players
doing that enough
oh he will you know he will he goes for
everything
yeah i paid for the game i'm gonna use
the whole movement that's that's what he
thinks
whoa
fancy
all right feng way arm kicking another
one's characters that just recently
coming off of some buffs
while standing too
oh that decides to get counted down back
please
and bang is that kind of character right
he can control the pace of mass like
this
aggression from titan or the down back
threes man they add up
exactly you know that new buff
uh giving it to countered extra damage
beautiful countering back one oh my
goodness just everything working right
now for titanfall
dude he is like a step ahead of every
poke
yeah he's non-stop rip look at him
all day what are you gonna do about it
fight
that's what everyone's waiting for now
you hyped this all up for the key
charges but honestly when you're playing
like this like you can just do it for
fun it's not necessary
oh beautiful four four neutral tube
oh no jason
here comes those iframes
look for the hard combos also titan
store though has rage gotta be super
careful he spends it immediately jason
up against the wall good with punishment
that was a beautiful bait there right he
dashed up oh we get a little pop off
okay
now he's gotta answer back you know he
has to
yo
the kick-up
that should have been a shoulder
with a convincing
game against jason game one we may not
have seen
any key charges whatsoever but you know
damn well titan thor does have the moves
that was ridiculous you know i mean you
said he was very fun to watch i was
waiting for the key charts but he didn't
need the key charges he had the right
idea for every single poke everything
was set up into something else right uh
which is great i love that he has oakey
off his combo instead of a down back
three counter it that was something i
haven't seen before uh so basically in
that situation if your opponent is
trying to do a get up kick that down
actually is gonna counter hit you there
and he's gonna get bonus damage right so
i really liked what i saw at titan thor
uh and you know everything else was just
perfect uh if i if i'm jason you gotta
slow down you know and you gotta like
look for some of these lows uh maybe
just take some of them right um and just
kind of wait for like the stuff that
he's trying to use basically like the
backswing blow etc so you can get the
bigger punishes because right now he's
just running his offense and it's like
here's the playbook
it's all working beautiful
and one of the things uh one of the
things that one uh
that my mentor
always told me about titan thor it's
pika by the way he's jules's brother um
he says titan thor is the kind of guy he
has the strength uh
that he doesn't he he doesn't normally
falter when it comes to his mix-ups not
working anymore he still doesn't but
each other he just changes the timing of
it for example if he if his damn
batteries have been blocked on reaction
over and over again he's still gonna do
it he's not scared
right and that's necessary
when you have a style like titan thor
where you're like this pure offensive
machine
uh you can't deviate from your game plan
or otherwise unless you have a really
strong backup game plan is really the
answer there uh but so far you know we
have yet to see it yet to need to see it
really
all right so twilight conflict number
two here selected by jason let's see if
there's any changes whatsoever
i was gonna say the punch counters could
be something we see coming out jackson
and he immediately comes with the game
too
wow where did that shoulder come from
it's literally the playbook bathroom
glow after everything yes oh my goodness
that's so cheap dude
he doesn't care the backswing flows and
then you know the goes for the lows also
titanfall is one crazy specimen justin
gets caught by the counter is this dead
it is yeah i i don't think he believed
he's going to finish that baby tattoo
down there you know
but all right right now tyson are
running away with it
jason definitely has slow things down a
video titan thor not just in his face
nonstop here giving him a different look
this time oh he's starting to style on i
see what's happening here
yeah he realizes the play in the pace of
titan thor
exactly that's gonna make it hard for
him i feel like when you play against a
fan player right bang is so good at
keeping life able to keep away oh my
goodness
okay here we go come back from johnson
can we see it is off the wall
oh no
the wall's in the way sidewall saving
the life
round three beautiful beautiful
not exactly that's a little bit scary
yeah he's still got it anyway so let's
see if we can continue this can he get
it to a game three titan thor still
continuing on with the impression
yeah that was a really good attempt for
the wildstar one from jason a second ago
just a little bit late on it
got him again oh oh there might be some
holes in the gameplay but he's got to
stop swinging through his geckos
hey
like bars close here
super star i love it now for both of
these guys
dude good conversion stuff
man these walls
are screwing over everybody the setups
he's backwards shoulder no shoulder oh
god
blue stuff green stuff
no stuff
round four
tied a thor
yo jason is adapting well here
he's got oh my god this punch counter is
so good good back one counter hit
the timings on the punch counters and
the back ones have been so good for
titanfall jason he tried to play in his
own his own pace but titan thor's
enforcing the aggression here one more
hit could do it and back for the
fishhook finishes jason off with the key
charge two to zero
very very nice there titan thor
advancing in the bracket uh that was fun
you know as as you expect he lived up to
the expectation that you set for us
there you know titan thor very fun fang
player to watch jason unfortunately does
fall to him here uh great armor king
played i really liked it i liked the
adaptation in game two uh just you know
a little bit too late i feel like we had
seen some of that adaptation in game one
then the whole set could have been a
little bit different but time thor
moving on will be going into that
loser's final of the pool to go up
against bran's maru later uh so that one
could be a good matchup as well time
thor uh the fang you know very very
crazy that first game that was a lot of
fun to watch i really like the pace he
played out there
and that's the thing about titan thor
yeah so
titanforce stays in your face no matter
what even
no matter how low his health is no
matter what situation you put him in no
matter what you know uh
you know
what kind of mix-ups you throw out of
he's still gonna be in your face because
that's how he plays and a lot of people
aren't ready for that you know there's
this standard tech and where if you're
low in health you gotta you gotta pick
up you gotta pick up the pace think
about what you're gonna do next without
thor's just throwing everything out and
it's really working out well for him so
there's a big chance he might make it a
top eight here
yeah he's he's got to get through mario
and you know that that's not gonna be
easy
uh but coming up next guys i do believe
we got coffee prince cover play going up
against ke meek uh tell me a little bit
about neat we all know conference d
flair now leroy you told me earlier uh
but but what about me
nick is a
yoshimitsu player
he was uh
he was in rev that one time
back in 2019 and
he was streamed also and that's all i
know of him he's a yoshimitsu player
really good also and
yeah
sounds like we got a good yoshimitsu
player incoming uh which is crazy right
because the yoshimitsu player making it
this part to the bracket because coffee
prince i'm pretty sure it's in the loser
final of his pool so you know nick
obviously making it through this bracket
we had over a hundred entrants by the
way this is not some kind of small
ranking tournament right lots of
entrants lots of top competitors so for
nick to make it this far the yoshimitsu
uh basically ninth place guaranteed here
can possibly make top eight if you can
get past cocker prince uh you know he's
gonna have a bag of tricks because
that's all what all yoshi mitsu players
have right they've all got this huge bag
of tricks and it's all about whether you
can survive it man uh do you guys have a
lot of yoshimitsu's out in the
philippines
no absolutely not
wow that's the thing about that's the
thing about yoshimitsu players i always
enjoy i i agreed upon this with my
friends that we always enjoy yoshimitsu
players like i musician uh
karee i think uh nick because
every yoshimitsu player that you see is
a different kind of issue you know what
i mean they have the exact setups they
have like different uh
how do you how do i word this properly
they're just really it's just really
cool for us to see that you know um
different minds with just the same
character that you see with
different setups and play styles play
styles that's what i mean exactly yeah
right yeah every yoshimitsu looks
different right they all have their own
unique way of playing the character and
they all have their own style with the
character because the character has so
many stances and so many options that of
ways that you could approach a match up
at any given moment that you know some
players favor like i'm gonna spin a lot
you know he's got the spin away tool or
they're gonna go i'm going to put my
sword away i'm going to you know that's
my style or i just want to run the okie
mix up on you all day you know i want to
go sword sweep all day sort of spin all
day or you know just do you know the qcf
one all day you know so there's a lot of
options for yoshimitsu or something just
very flash heavy of course how can i
forget right uh but definitely a very
versatile character a lot of different
ways you can approach them so i'm very
excited to see what we get out of neat
here uh coffee prince you know you
mentioned he's been running the leroy a
lot lately uh but personally i i want to
see the steve fox but against yoshimitsu
run the leroy just
you can just carry all those sword
things you know you don't got to deal
with them like other characters got deal
like yoshi is like quick unblockable if
he does things sometimes you know if
they're late you compare it with leroy
other characters most of the characters
you don't really have a choice
yeah and you know coffee prince isn't
only uh a leroy plus steve he also
uh from time to time fakumra he
and do you think [ __ ] runs like the
better choice here compared to leroy or
is it still heroin
i think bakaram is always a good choice
though like that character was nerfed a
little bit but uh i think he's still a
very strong character i didn't realize
that coffee prince was such a cheater
you know steve when he was really good
and then he switches to leroy and focus
okay i see you coffee prince
but all right here with the ocean
no yeah of course no dude this is a
tournament right there's a lot online
here uh thousands of dollars in these
tournaments if you make the week of
finals we'll triple that so we'll see
what happens here
cochran bringing out the leroy
and nick here with the yoshimitsu
game on
interrupting knee challenging a lot of
these throws sidestep the f2 knee gonna
carry towards that wall but just a bit
short
is looking really sharp here but that
back one plus two shotgun
yeah 12 frame mid counter hit launcher
that's pretty good
and the main nerf that they gave that
move
sorry the main nerf that they gave that
move is that it has a lot more recovery
frames right oh no okay
wake up flash
round two
i'm starting to see the play style
coming through here
right here again with the coffin breaker
coffee prince follows up with the combo
we're gonna see a wall big diamonds
coming in from coffee prince
that was a great setup
i love that what's for okay here though
this is the yoshimitsu special right
dude that was tight it was a hawking
bait
just out of range and the that should be
it the wild thing to hear leeroy's gonna
do enough damage and he's gonna spend
the rage art
man oh man he did
he didn't need to do that but he did he
wanted the breathing time so it's all
right
one round a piece here and you know if
i'm weaker like i hope he's not like
intimidated by just player coffee prince
right because right now he can get this
done it's looking very doable
interesting choice there maybe thought
the wall was gonna be there i'm not sure
good block wow
you're still done uh i mean i don't
think he needed to do the rage art at
all you know i think that's like he was
gonna kill him anyway but to just wake
up and throw out the orbital was pretty
crazy
and he is really good man dude nick is
so good hitting these launchers too the
downpour 2 has been working the hockey's
working the wall combos have been pretty
terrible though
oh yeah for sure he's been going for a
lot more setups here but copy friends
guessing right every single time
all right survive the king
bringing some health back i like what
i'm seeing dude where did it come from
no sword no sword
okay
that's that's kind of fake he wanted the
fast flash
got him that's such a good move now dude
that move is so much better now
safer on block
used to be launched
not so like minus 13 or minus 12.
oof
no wall splat but he got him this time
oh there it is
1-1 all day
uh it's definitely with one of those
downford 1-1 strings where it's hard to
duck the second hit and get a good
punish on it uh a lot of players seem to
get caught by that second hit of it uh
but there you go kaiju prince leroy
looking sharp a lot of that back one
plus two that shotgun right uh that move
right there leroy as i mentioned 12
frame mid countered launcher tool uh no
other character has anything like that
in the entire game the weakness of it
the range is short and there's a lot of
recovery after it so the idea is you're
supposed to you know make it with and
then launch punishment for it because it
actually is vulnerable for a lot longer
than it appears so that's kind of the
answer for it that people don't really
take advantage of
it's still baffling to me the fact that
it's 12 frame
it's a 12 frame counter hit launcher
plus it's safe it doesn't matter it
doesn't even matter if it has short
range the fact of the matter is it's 12
frames come on man yep
hey look man as a as someone who plays
lyra as well it's perfect
it's exactly what it needs to be
do you think law needs something like
that you know
no a lot of does he need something no
law needs his auto parry back all right
give law his auto parry back give him
give what law actually needs is a usable
rage drive uh he needs a
uh a power crush that's not terrible uh
right i mean he's got a power cause it's
a wall bounce but then they already
nerfed the clean head damage on that 443
right so then they take away the damage
it's the launch punch will announce
power quest for the wall bounce but
who's gonna use it you're gonna get
killed from trying it right uh give me
back my wall damn give me back that
clean hit that's that's all i really
want give me back to clean and damn i
feel like that would that would be all i
need for a while
yeah a large rage drive is pretty
to where it properly interesting because
you know not a lot of people use it it
it can be low buried um it's seeable um
i think you meant trash
uh i was trying to be nice come on i was
trying to be nice
uh yeah it's interesting
uh no but no really you know
12 frame mid that's what we're talking
about right the leroy move is very good
it's necessary um
and
i don't think it's necessary i mean even
if that move is 13 phases would still be
really good it's
necessary yeah all right maybe i
overstated that a little bit uh but
leroy is still a very strong character
uh he does have some weaknesses though
right so
we'll we'll see how this character
actually plays out obviously you know
with everything changing online with
cover and everything uh we didn't really
get to see the full arc of leroy right
we only got to see the very beginning of
it offline uh the character has been
nerfed multiple times and you know we
across the world we haven't really seen
leroy's like dominating still uh so this
would be a very interesting example if
prince can win the tournament with leroy
because i'm still not seeing this
character win so at this point right now
now that i've said all that i kind of
want to see coffee first win this
tournament with leroy because the
character is great right he's i don't
think he's like top top top tier but
he's still great uh coffer is a great
player so he can get it done like this
is a great opportunity when this can
happen but let's not forget conference
prince is in the loser bracket for a
reason too like i don't know what
character he used how he ended up there
uh but somebody beat him
yeah and you know um
we that that is true right leroy we
haven't been seeing him win a lot lately
because of the
simply because of the small nerfs that
he received in the
in the most recent patches right
and the character we've been seeing a
lot more that wins tournaments is lydia
and i did ask maru who we did mention
earlier
maru used libya earlier
and we've seen how much uh
we've seen the waves that lydia has been
making in recent tournaments also that
you know lydia winning from east asia to
south asia pretty damn good character
although not the best but still super
super effective
right yeah lydia is certainly this
character has kind of been talking about
recently it's like is this the top five
character uh is this something that you
know people should be talking about more
and people forget lydia's only been out
for like four months you know three to
four months this character is still very
very new you know uh you know despite
what people say this game is still you
know in a state of progression right
like players are still figuring out the
characters and all the matchups you know
the meta is far from solved you know
here we are 2021 the season four uh we
still have a lot to learn about the game
yeah and speaking of a lot to learn
you're definitely gonna see a lot to
learn from copy prince here again
with the amount of aggression that he's
putting on nick when it should have been
meek with the setups also as a
yoshimitsu infinite azure so a lot of
spacing gonna happen here in this game
let's see one is here so far for coffee
prince ladies and gentlemen time to take
out the trash
infinite stage here yoshimitsu is a very
interesting character because
when you have him at the wall he's got a
bunch of tech traps for you but when you
have infinite stage
he's also still very good
yeah and he has checked for this whole
situation right
boom
i feel like we just talked about that
move
okay okay there's
he's been getting hopkins so much that
he's like i'm going mid here you know
i'm like not gonna let a chance for a
low crush off here to kill me and bring
his comeback
no sir oh no punish there
yeah and league again trying to go with
four more aggression the coffee prince
stopping me stopping him with the back
one plus two that's been killing him for
the longest time now
[Music]
damn the intro for the down one two
there
and just like that it's set point for
copy prince
[Music]
got him kabuki me
fight
that flash
wow oh my god that was such a dirty bait
he didn't down four or two on block into
back one plus two
with the flash falls over the combo
what's he gonna go for goes for full
damage
nick one last chance one combo and he
could kill cocky prince here interrupts
generic down four copy prince closes it
out two to zero
very nicely done coffee prince moving on
here in the tournament well played
coffee prince neat fun yoshimitsu i feel
like he had it you know if you go back
in the first game i feel that first game
he didn't get caught by so many back
oneplus 2s uh and those those couple
really clutch orbitals end around and
stuff uh that copper prince is using uh
but unfortunately he is out of the
tournament
yeah for sure now guys if you want to
hear more news about the second online
challenge here is the schedule for all
the new dates for online masters and
regional finals just listed down here
guys make sure you write it down or
screenshot it or whatever this is the
schedule
exactly and of course you see the
philippines east asia regional final
going to be in early december there
december 4th so that's what these
players are trying to get into right
they're trying to gather these points so
that they can get their spot secured for
that regional finals event
and don't forget guys the online dojos
applications you need to submit them by
october 10th i believe this was actually
extended or i'm tripping but i'm pretty
sure you guys got to get this in
basically right you guys want to get
your dojo points you guys are tournament
admins you guys want to submit that
application as soon as possible deadline
approaching quickly just nine more days
to get your event listed as part of the
online dojo system
oh definitely this as well guys if you
guys did not know you guys do have to
link your accounts to the esports
tournament portal make sure you guys do
that uh this has been extended this is
the one that has been extended it was
supposed to be october 1st i believe
they pushed it back to october 8th so
you got one more week
visit the website that you see on your
screen right now to double check that
you are registered a lot of people were
registered for the beta version of this
so they were linked at that point and
you have to do it again basically so uh
just make sure you're registered for the
actual official season that your points
are counted uh if you saw the
leaderboard earlier like hey you know
that guy's one point i know i had at
least one point i'm supposed to be there
too this is probably the reason why so
make sure you guys check out the website
make sure you're registered and make
sure you sign up for this official
season
all right so guys make sure you do
follow us at our socials that's on
twitter bme esports as well as tekken
and on youtube you can follow them you
can subscribe at bnb esports on twitch
it's tekken as well as facebook facebook
again guys that is tekken on twitter
twitch and facebook and on another
twitter you should follow is vietnamese
and on youtube it's vme esports
exactly there'll be any esports channels
where you can find all the clips and
everything happen in the tournaments as
well as some of the postmatch highlights
etc uh that's definitely where you wanna
go and grab all that information but
guys we do have to take a quick break a
tekken online challenge philippines and
east asia will continue after this we'll
be right back
i gotta do it too
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i fought all types of fighters in my
time
but who knows what other crazy strong
guys are still out there
now to get stronger than ever before
i've had enough now i'm mad frieza i'm
not gonna lie it's tense times like
these that really get me pumped for a
[ __ ] humming
but what i do know is that i'd like to
avoid fighting if i can and just let him
go later you guys i hope you're reborn
as someone good this time
[Music]
i can't wait to find out
range
arrive to destination
[Music]
enemy reinforcements check your radars
[Music]
[Music]
box too
[Music]
and rip that's exactly why i lost it at
the 10 frame launcher oh hey i didn't
see you there welcome back to tekken
online challenge 2021 we are your
commentators kid and rip back at it
again rip how you've been doing
tell me about the match that we just saw
earlier
dude the mats have been a lot of fun
here obviously conference with leroy we
just saw advancing uh i do believe that
we're kind of secured in our top eight
so far and there is a lot of philippines
representation in this of course and
guys don't forget astro the official
headset and mix amp of the tekken online
challenge 2021 big shout out to astro
supporting all things tekken throughout
the year uh but yes going back to this
tournament you know a lot online here
these guys are battling for their points
and trying to make that regional finals
huge prize pulls all around this event
and the regional files itself so a lot
to play for today uh but you know the
matches coming up are going to be
crazier the ones we've already seen of a
lot of fun as well uh and the
philippines you know as expected are
doing very well in this tournament
oh yeah and we already have our top
eight here
decided in our brackets and we're just
gonna show you that in just a little bit
but right now i do wanna announce who's
in our uh top eight in the winter side
we have jules versus t-rex and next up
will be ak versus tomorrow now rip i
want to talk to you about tomorrow real
quick because i mentioned this
off-stream but i'll mention it for
everyone here in the chat right now and
now to all the viewers that we have
tomorrow just started taking tekken
seriously late uh late 2019 and he was
under the tutelage of one of the best
king players in uh the philippines um
rock and roll which sadly enough he's
not here in the tournament but he has
been
making a lot of results and you know
performing really really well so there's
a lot and he's only going to get better
he's still so young just tomorrow kid
right so uh how young is he do you have
any idea
is he likes 13 years old 17 or 20 okay
that you know the young the wrong how
how are you kid you got the name kid
it's a funny name because the older you
get let me tell you it's not going to
work
but like we're like my early early 20s
yourself mid twenties big guess take a
guess come on
i'm gonna go with 24.
25. 29. 34.
i'm 23. anyway here we have the match
jules versus t-rex and yes i am indeed
23 and i have a name for a kid let's
whatever it's whatever man i'm old
enough to be your father that's crazy
bringing out eddie
sorry i meant you're old enough to be my
father uh t-rex versus jewels here
eddie gordo versus bob
i hope you're ready
round one
let's see how things are gonna go t-rex
again jules has a lot of experience when
it comes to the eddie match-up but you
know
eddie is also a very different character
here so let's see how juice is going to
make it count
yeah a lot of wall pressure right now i
think bob is definitely one of these
characters that's underrated right now
too
uh we're seeing more and more bobs come
out and they're putting themselves on
the map uh i don't want to see a return
of second six mob
and ever since texas like he's left the
stain in my mind you know my brain juice
i think about bob like no no i don't
want to see it
right now
bob's into me in tekken 6 and i i've
never been in the competitive side of
the second six so i'm really i want to
know this from you but uh that's for
later so let's see jules though has a
t-rex up against the wall against the
counter hit launcher
oh yeah
t-rex god duels back up here get the
bounce and that should be the round
[Music]
ties it up one piece fight
really really good showing sake of the
t-rex not a lot of people can get that
momentum back especially when jules
takes it in the first round back to
picks up
that was a crazy attempt at running
through that the techno worked out well
i remember one of the weaknesses in this
matchup specifically used to be that if
eddie went relaxed bob's back to his
have issues but oh boy never mind it's
flawless
why didn't i talk about it round four
that's the demonstration
so good
yeah you gotta be ready for it
oh my goodness all day
he really did it four times
make it five he's trying to get away
from the wall yeah i try to get away
from the wall kick out of nowhere and
jules then i carry to the wall dave
davis coming in gonna put him in rage
yes
can he close it out though t-rex
opportunity gotta watch out for that
rager when eddie's back to the wall not
gonna get it
[Music]
immediately jules again i'm telling you
man jules is someone you would have to
keep your eyes on because this guy
been winning a lot of tournament not
winning a lot of tournaments but been
joining top eights in recent tournaments
and only recently he did he win uh
tatakai pilipinas which is the most
recent tournament here we had here in
in the philippines jules
definitely a scary name to behold
exactly and this is first the two here
this is winner semi-finals in the top
eight right now so jules one game away
from making into that top three of
course uh and you know t-rex didn't look
terrible in that game but uh jules is
all over really smothering him ready for
the relax mix up any time that he would
go into relax the back dude was there uh
other than that the pressure was on
there and obviously we all know eddie
doesn't have a really good side step so
a lot of the times when you have that
coming you know like what's that he can
do with bob just continually pressure
you in that situation he's gonna have to
try to force a relaxed mix up
essentially right uh so we'll see what
he tries to bring here in game two but
uh looks like it's an uphill battle for
sure
yeah and that's the tricky part about
this matchup right eddie has a lot of
stances that can get picked up by bob
with just in just one input alone which
is the back too it's so risky to go for
a hand a handstand mix up or even the
even the relaxed stance because it can
just be negated by the back too so it's
it's such a super super risky character
to play against bob so do you think the
character switch might happen here
you know it could be but and i know this
is it's kind of like taboo almost to
talk about nowadays because me and arson
actually been switching characters so
much but i feel like there are still a
lot of character loyalists out there you
know and uh unless you really have that
secondary built up uh it's very very
difficult to switch characters and
tournaments i think you know knee and
arsenate are obviously exceptions to
this rule uh chicken another player who
has a couple of a few characters you can
use but unless you've been using these
characters like five to ten years you
know until like the top eight top four
of a tournament it's really hard to
bring out your secondaries unless you're
really really comfortable with them but
here we go game two t-rex sticking it
out with eddie gordo
uh and i like what i'm seeing here you
know eddie cordo definitely is a
character that if you're running him in
tournament you probably don't have a
secondary because otherwise you would be
using the secondary
and this is so interesting because t-rex
lost that game one but he didn't go for
an infinite stage which normally you
would see eddie go for you know stages
to move around and you know just back
dash in but this time he chose island
paradise
yeah he used a new back two three right
there a second ago that's something i
want to see him see more out of eddie
like that's definitely one of the best
tools that's gotten added but beautiful
jewels with the whip on his crouch one
look at that
that was
he's crazy that situation in line for
t-rex but no he changes the position
instead this might be bad for jules
though he's so close to that balcony
break
that was terrifying i do not ever want
to play jules after seeing that
bro jules running through t-rex right
now one round away getting to the top
three of this tournament
looking real strong working on a sweep
here jules looking for
once but t-rex is kind of struggling to
find an opening for jules right now the
defense is so good
and you saw just a second ago that
relaxed he tried to go underneath the
pressure but the back two immediately
pushed him out and the get up kicks
getting a counter hit here
walt's wall beautiful conversion smart
stuff from duels all around
look at this wow
amazing pickup from jewels and one more
hit to do with wrong punish from t-rex
and that's a clean 2-0 for jules against
t-rex sends him to the losers bracket
and jules moves on to winners final
exactly top three guaranteed for jules
congratulations sir uh but that as you
called it out clean victory there you
know he looked like he knew everything
about eddie uh was not fazed by the
character choice whatsoever and you know
when you're that comfortable against the
character it doesn't even matter who the
player is you're like i know all the
options for all the tricks you've got
coming at me uh and really that looked
like a really hard character match up uh
specifically you know if you're t-rex
there and you don't have another
character jules is really prepared for
that and to be that prepared against bob
i feel is much harder uh because bob is
so much uh you know so many
how do i say this politely
so much garbage and that he can throw at
you with like those power questions etc
uh you know so
nicely done by jules i'm glad to see bob
on the map you know at this stage of
tournament i think as i mentioned
earlier an underrepresented character uh
so it's really nice to see him get this
far
and a fun fact about jules is that his
brother pika who is also his coach
pika has been playing eddie
uh a lot especially in his streams he's
been telling people how
how good eddie is
and the fact that you know it showed how
well jules played against t-rex no he
it just shows how well he how well he's
prepared for that match-up basically no
he's and now i'm so prepared
yeah for sure up next though in our
winners uh winners bracket in top eight
we do have everyone's been waiting for
this kid
ak
versus tomorrow ladies and gentlemen
this is something that everyone is
excited for obviously aka he's you know
he's been the most known player outside
of the philippines right from the
philippines outside the philippines so
it's always exciting for us to take a
look at them but in these sorts of
tournaments this is your opportunity to
make a name for yourself right you
mentioned tomorrow starting up really in
2019
which is kind of crazy it's like just
before the world shut down in a sense uh
so yeah this is a huge stage you know as
we're kind of rebuilding back to like
potential offline terms returning right
uh so i'm excited to see this one you
mentioned he's a jaguar man right or is
it only king yeah
he uses king and armor king but you know
recently he's been playing noctis so he
might pull out the noctis here and if it
doesn't work he's probably going to go
for the armor king
yeah ak of course we've seen time and
time again
but look at this
wow
wow okay and aka with the [ __ ] take into
account yeah
you know when you're trying to win
you're trying to win uh
damn all right tomorrow let's see what
you got here
with the [ __ ] rob
aka with the shane classic
let's see how effective this is
here in this infinite stage also so a
lot of movement can happen in this game
oh
he's trying to break those pokemon legs
early
he's taking his time right now breaking
his legs and we talked about ak being
persistent with whatever move he decides
to go with him right now he's breaking
the leg and there's the low parry
tomorrow calls up for the combo jk put
outside of rage this is really good for
tomorrow hero but instagram standing
free weird stuff coming from tomorrow
here also
gotta watch a rage drive here running
three and tomorrow
gets the first round in the set
no convert he didn't try to convert i
think he could have got him there
yeah unfortunately
ak follows up the combo full damage
somewhere you're almost at half health
if you try to go for the slide there you
saw that
oh yeah
yo jet kick
[Music]
man unfortunate trade there for tomorrow
again trying to open him up with the
loads this time but ak's also doing the
same but the timing is there for the
launcher and ak finishes him off one
round a piece
yeah that was a really good call out on
the downfall too because he had such a
big likely that tomorrow had to come in
right so he's just waiting for the
timing on that downpour too because he's
like you're gonna run into something
eventually it's gonna be this launcher
great
hit by the orbital and he killed this
combo i don't think so though
what the okay rage mode [ __ ] rom
the same situation right he's got the
life lead
tomorrow canvas getting hit by get a
kick left ak off the ground
[Music]
round four that timing from ak down
three as soon as tomorrow tried to
approach but the thunder kick tomorrow
catches him again gets before combo win
oh my goodness
break it
it's all adding up good punishment he's
gonna do it again again he's gonna do it
again one minute out of here he drive is
gonna stop him in his tracks tomorrow
takes it to a final round
yo ak's a nut
down 4-2 for the keep out this time
oh my god
all right i've been talking a lot trash
by shaheen but ak made me want to play
him right there
break his
tomorrow legs he done for here in this
one no one more hit to do it is he gonna
lower he's gonna know yes he will aka
closes it out convincingly taking it
against tomorrow one to zero
what a jerk that was fantastic that was
fantastic uh aka doing ak things out
here uh and yeah it was so good right
because he's timing on the orbital there
after he set him with so many lows like
he's like no he's not gonna do anything
about these lows until i bring out the
orbital then he's going to dug for it it
was just so well played and you know
when you're ak you've done this 100
times 100 players you know it's just
another one in your list so for everyone
else you're like he's not going to do it
again he's not going to it's going to do
it again and then you start panicking
right now now you know your mind is all
over the place you don't know which way
to look you don't know which way to
block
uh it's looking kind of rough to be
honest
and one of the biggest highlights for ak
is also back way back in evil japan
where he got second place remember that
right you were there evil japan aka he
fought against cbm he did five slides in
a row against him and cvm did not block
that's the type of playstyle aka is
bringing to the table with us right now
and he's still doing it to this day
yeah it doesn't matter what kick you
know earlier we're talking about like
the akuma option that he had before
right uh what he was just down for you
like nine times in a row he he's very
persistent with one move and
you don't as a player when you're going
against something like that you don't
expect it even though you've seen him do
it time and time again to so many
players you still don't think it's going
to happen he's like he's he can't like
why would he do it seven times in a row
that makes no sense to me
but sure enough we get a character
switch we get
armor king this time uh bringing out for
tomorrow and of course this character
as we mentioned earlier a little bit
stronger now we've seen more and more
armor kings showing up in tournaments
uh ak though with the shaheen keep them
on the map
oh yeah i i love that uh i love that
armor king is getting a lot of
representation here especially in the
philippines that nobody not a lot of
people use him it's uh
you know just a couple of my friends and
not much in top eight tournaments so
this is really this is refreshing to see
wow doubt the wildfire just out of range
that time
i can't believe you heard me it's the
caster's curse tomorrow the nut punch
we're gonna carry to the wall there it
is tomorrow welcome
aka okay combo doesn't break the giant
swing he's dead oh face first to the
wall downtown tomorrow first round
nicely done there
yeah playing a bit more slow this time
around
yeah it's kind of odd right okay
yo break his legs all day go back to
that it was working oh and that's why it
was working
you know and that's the seeds that were
planted in game one
okay again the slides not a single one
has been blocked by tomorrow but the
timing on the launcher again ak catches
him and takes it one round a piece we've
seen this movie before fight
exactly and you know that that's the
game plan right now right he wants to
get him frustrated that when he has a
life he comes running in and then the
dow 402 is there for the keep out you
know prior to that it's all the low
pokes it slides uh to really break his
defense right now you can see tomorrow
he's guessing on everything
delayed hockey punish
speaking of guessing aka did guess right
there he blocked the low and now he's
one round away from sending tomorrow
to the losers bracket
dude that down 42 is from downtown
breaks the last wall here we're going
this way though
tomorrow you're showing some signs of
life here aka looking for more slide
mix-ups uh mix-ups in so we're playing a
bit more safely this time gotta be
careful about that launcher though the
df2 good break on the shining wizard
yeah that's a great point he really has
to stay away from this
and not get caught by downpour two when
he's trying to get some off and start
himself
rage motor
ak
rate drive of course
good patience there by tomorrow there
they try to use the delay to bait him
into it but no go oh final round game
two
tomorrow not out of it yet dying swing a
multi-throw could be huge
on point with punishment tomorrow there
so you know his head is still in the
game no duck on the second hit but ak
continuing the aggression that's the
first flight and that's the first slide
that he blocked this entire set tomorrow
right now working on
getting into a game three what's he
going to do
dice when the wall could kill here
[Music]
oh good attack
god
showing some signs of life i love it
tomorrow adjusting perfectly well now
aka is very comfortable with the stage
this is nor this is normally his go-to
stage whenever he loses a match right
the howard estate so we might go for an
instant rematch here or
he might go for a geometric plane which
we've been seeing quite a lot in the
recent tournament that we've had here
interesting you know i i really like the
army king player that's coming out of
tomorrow so far uh obviously the biggest
question mark here is you know those
seeds that were planted by ak in the
first game with the lows repeatedly
you're breaking his legs mixing up with
the slides now in game two you know
where is the defense going to be in game
three uh and when you play this game
that aka is playing it gets a little
risky right because you know these
things are very punishable on block if
you can guess correctly so ak's really
counting on these things to pay off uh
but you know if tomorrow's defense holds
up here uh and he's blocking standing
for the majority time here it's gonna be
like a lot easier for him but that being
said that's the whole mind game right
like it's easier to stand and guard and
take all the lows but against ak you
know he's willing to do 10 lows in a row
so
it's a very interesting mind game
we'll see what happens but i'm very
curious and obviously we saw the one
giant swing worked out before we were
earlier uh it's something he tried to go
back to again ak was ready for the
breaks the second time i would love to
see you know some of those commandos the
multi-throws that arm king has come into
play
oh yeah
boys and girls
no mix-up mix-up is a real thing
you got to be careful when you're
fighting ak because he will do the same
thing over and over again until you
eventually manage to like block one or
two of those so again we're sticking
with the howard estate stage this is
ak's comfort pick
but let's see if tomorrow can close this
one out against you know the guy the
stars of the entire uh this entire
country aka
exactly this is the time to get your
name on the map
low parry from ak
it's been primarily all offense right
and keep on the key charge you were
talking about it yeah
get into the wall and key charge for the
mix
oh
he's going to get the wall break also
unfortunate stuff
he misses the second hit of the scorpion
kicks
rage mode last pixel just a little short
a little desperate there with the grab
attempt
uh didn't even get the full shining
aka first round
yeah for sure here we go down four
that's only the first one tomorrow is he
gonna block those ak's looking for more
orbital heels
there it is again three
oh no oh he canceled okay okay ak ready
for defensively as well
slides are coming
i don't think so oh goodness
so
the slides and then goes for the big mid
ak
super good conditioning here
block the slide this time here comes
tomorrow small combo off that slide you
need to block eight slides to win that
round that's not going to happen
gonna get carried to the wall t-chart
set up
is he gonna go
up against him
ak with the showboat takes it against
tomorrow two to one sending him to the
loser's bracket rip what i tell you
what'd i tell you man did you tell me
i expected that to happen all along what
were you telling me um
ak he's a k he's the star of the
philippines he's moving into the
winner's final top three guaranteed
congratulations aka tomorrow though he
looked pretty good there right obviously
the conditioning came into play you're
spot on about that as well uh you know
and tomorrow unfortunately does have to
go down to that loser bracket that shark
infested loser bracket of course waiting
for the winner between rgn and sidestep
lance uh we also got t-rex down the
loser back we saw him lose to jules
earlier he's he's waiting for the winner
between coffee prince and maru uh so
lots of crazy action still to come here
we're just getting started but we do
have a winner's final squared away at
least later tonight will be omega's
jewels versus pves ak
oh such an exciting match to see
everybody's been seeing this you know
match up over and over again and quite
frankly they don't get tired of it they
this kind of matchup jules versus ak in
the world oh yeah and this isn't even
granted
i mean we might get it for grand finals
too right we'll see how we'll see how
this loser bracket plays out this is
gonna be a good one uh ak shaheen
definitely very fun to watch uh you know
some of my friends have been trying to
get me to play shaheen uh and shaheen
to me is just so boring but watching 8k
playing right now i gotta say it's it's
a little bit more interesting you know
but i feel like you have to have that
mentality which i don't have you know
the i'm gonna break your legs 30 times
in a row until you duck my orbital you
know that's his old game plan and the
way he does that with all of his
characters right is just so effective
and so good so huge shout out to ak uh
for being able to make sure he look
interesting
because most people don't do it for me
god
uh i mean i see sukin in the chat right
now you know calling you out for what
you're saying right now but
you know
sucks
it came from him
i have i i refuse to take part in this
conversation anyway
this is the beauty of being like in the
comments data chair you know you can say
what you want they can't respond really
sorry go ahead lose your bracket
so yeah losers bracket we do have tgr's
rgn going up against gm side stoplights
that we did see sidestep lance earlier
with the lee chaolan and rgn with the
akuma now arjun he didn't he never had
his matches stream but i have seen a
couple of personal streams that they
found rgn and rgn's crazy good so you
know i'm really excited
yeah i'm trying to take a look at the
bracket and see who rjnb to get in here
because i think he was in pool one yeah
so he took out mr good and he took out s
and georgie so ss george he did get the
run back with hop on so he actually
doubled jeopardy japan out of the
tournament uh and then fell to rgn right
after that and then arjen over mr good
so here we are rgn versus sidestep lance
okay now what do you think of this
matchup akuma versus lee challan i don't
see this matchup every day
this is definitely not a match that we
see every day uh and you know
going back to lee being the back four
master like my question here is does
back four beat like demon flip does it
beat jump in like i feel like it
probably does it's the answer for
everything usually uh we'll see man i'm
curious to see how this one goes
okay
be super careful about that meters is
building up for rj and also especially
in the latter half of this uh
set besides the plants good block rgn
down three
[Music]
slide fail
good whiff punch for the doubt himself
there
oh no again so on point back to
he's been conditioning sidestep plans
for the down threes and can he continue
on to the wall yes look at this damage
that was beautiful that was perfect
combo there right it all started with
the cow right upstairs got the balcony
break down there had the screws still
into the wall carry for the combo and
death very nice round for rgn
is
closing the gap out with uh running 3-4
this is really good for him but so far
it's not working out rgn has him up
against the wall the wall bounces
next can he carry no he drops it
it's okay he's still got a huge lead
here tries to land some big trouble
uh right now it is everything going rg
in favor his timing on the defense has
been ridiculous
all right there's the slide
they're waiting inside that time
the timing just wasn't there and wasn't
enough for sidestep last rgn gets caught
out of the air after happening yeah that
backpack
there you go
counter it down three inside that lance
we talked about earlier being just a
little bit slow on the download right a
little slow starter picking up as the
set goes on and we're kind of seeing a
little bit of that again right now
yeah might be playing into the palm of
his hands those sides have plans he just
needs a bit of more time to download rgn
but rgn is playing so well against
knight supplants it's insane ff3 catches
him off guard he's so close to the wall
though be careful
yeah he's got full meter now as well
nice side then
do attack we break here nice get the
break little spanx
with just a sliver of health takes game
one
that was amazing back and forth there at
the end you saw though you know size of
that started to put the pieces together
right the puzzle was almost complete
there so game two is gonna be really
interesting here
uh the first couple rounds are rough
right you can see the download there i
really like the added adaptive
adaptation that's coming out of size to
plan so far but uh a little bit too late
there and you know down to the wire
there uh it was just unfortunate right
the cooper common drops i feel like when
you're playing specifically in an online
tournament and you're going against an
akuma right anytime they hit you with a
down to combo you down back and you wait
for them to potentially whiff that combo
right because it's such a good strategy
right the potential for dropping is so
much higher so you got to just hope for
that and he had an opportunity there but
he didn't he didn't expect to drop and
then he ducked after the drop and ate
the while standing too right so uh you
personally that's my personal strategy
if i'm going against an akuma online i'm
like he's going for a combo started down
to i'm down backing i am down backing
that's uh that's pretty brave you know
that's pretty what if you get hit by the
twin pistons so
he's gonna he's gonna stop his car but
do a twin piston no way you're right i'm
waiting for that effort he's gonna miss
or something
he's not gonna
look because i said it now they're gonna
know about it right but
they're not gonna know
all right somebody use shaheen
somebody use akuma against rip the next
time they dm and use a he's a twin
piston just for my sake
drop your combo intentionally and twin
piston me go for it
i'm looking forward you know i'm just
gonna stand guard now
[Laughter]
perfect
mind games through commentary game two
rgn sidestep lance
uh yeah forgot realm uh good choice here
and you saw it there why right the back
four he's like if you ever go airborne i
catch his back four we're going down and
getting a combo
yeah the jab isn't entirely the most um
reliable in this case because
he's such a small character backwards
the most reliable you won't have the
the most reliable one you have oh rgn
gets away from the wall risky situation
didn't that meter yet couldn't do much
that fireball
back four range is much better now
see that down back there you down back
there as soon as you get your
fireball fadc you down back
but he didn't do anything come on i mean
yeah that's perfect if he did do
something and he missed you're great
all right maybe you got a point good
lunch oh no he missed it df2 just by
afraid he missed the punish
whoa
you know that was a mistake for a
fireball probably there
bounce
i'm gonna go downstairs also big damage
coming from sidestep plans but
that's out of rage good
catch by sidestep flats and there it is
the armor rgn gets caught and this is
what we were talking about guys
seriously with the downloads
yeah very good adaptation
let's see if you can keep the momentum
rolling right now
it's almost like a comfort oh my god i
love it
i love it
coming from a llama like you rip i know
you would then here we go size of class
let's hope he does more and rgn low
perry pulls up the combo no he drops it
fadc gets another combo in all worth it
where are we going can't reach the wall
here too far
rain chart
takes it to a game three again don't
count this guy out just because he loses
game one he will take it to a game three
and you're seeing a lot of combos that
aren't fully executed right like a lot
of these something in f8c into nothing
uh mistakes that are happening and you
really have to take advantage of right
like obviously online offline there are
separate you have to treat them as
separate uh and again akuma specifically
you know i think he's starting to
recognize during these fpdc conversions
there's opportunities to be had uh so
we'll see if you can keep it together uh
but right now i think seismic lance is
looking really good in the set you know
we talked about it earlier the download
he's slow starter you know but once you
put the piece of the puzzle together uh
things are looking a lot better for him
so
it's looking a little rough for rgm
you might have to switch the stage
though because this is um sidestep
lance's comfort stage the forgotten rump
might want to go for you know some more
a more honest stage like mashima dojo
maybe even go for the infinity because
akuma still kind of works in the
infinite stage given you know
two two meters right
right yeah and akuma i feel like with
the wall though the damage potential is
so high you kind of just want to keep it
and with the tech catch potential
afterwards uh we already saw a size and
glance at some tech cats too probably
caught our jan off guard with it so you
know going forward obviously our jet
will probably be a little more cautious
with his tech rolls at the wall
uh especially in situations where the
wall combo isn't like a complete wall
combo right those usually tells that the
combo is lead to some sort of tech trap
and instead he goes for the dragon's
nest so a bit of a weirdly shaped stage
but there is still a wall present here
so it might work out better for rgn
considering akuma can dish out a ton of
damage especially with full meter
well let's see what happens final game
here losers bracket top eight action
no go
kick counter hit follows up with the
combo
rgn big damage is he gonna go for the
okay no it goes for a full combo
hey chop him up
oh down three he's gonna push for that
wall bounce again
no why would you risk it
[Music]
in big trouble again the chop finishes
him off rgn with round one
yeah that four two one was back to the
wall like that was not the best call out
right there right
i'm not even sure like it didn't look
like it was for a whiff fighter i think
so that was an odd choice for size have
lance uh but he really just gave the
round to rgn with that no oh boy
yeah and again right you're seeing the
meter usage beautiful bait
that was wonderful
combo
yeah
okay slice the plants goes for the okay
combo finishes off with a down three and
now one round a piece again saisa plants
with a slow download
and he's taking it back
the beautiful slides are working
good down for i like that after the back
farm surprise surprises reached
oh no oh my god armor
he doesn't even use the meter here he's
going to carry to the wall but he drops
the combo still carries sidestep wall
sidestep glance
to the wall and now he's in big trouble
what's the okay here
wait oh my god no excuse me
while said to ant here stay with the
oaky slides good double rage 50 50 no he
tried the big sweep good defense from
rgn to hold on set point rgm
okay now what can sites the plants do
here goes for the oaky on that slide but
no
friends wants to make him guest down
three counter hit and this is the follow
up on the combo fadc full combo
definitely
combo incoming tries for the wall bounce
empty jump on accident get them out of
there for a second but it's not gonna be
enough our jet opportunity to close it
out right now wave more precise at land
not enough to kill 50 50 the chops
blocked
why oh he whips
big whip from side step lands to end
with punish from rgn on the down three a
bit of a questionable decision from
sidestep laster given the fact that it
wasn't enough range but you can count on
rgn to whip punish that perfectly big
props to rgn and you know
congratulations to side suspense for
making it this far but unfortunately he
is now eliminated
rgn is still in uh size of lancer
limited yes uh rgn though man he looked
really good there uh and man that last
attempt from that it's just
heartbreaking because he he had the
chance right like he survived the combo
he blocked the mix up afterwards yeah
you know he just needed to do something
with more range you know in those
situations it's kind of hard to go out
with rage too right like especially have
a rage drive like like just kind of
throw it out there if it hits and hits
you know you might make the whole
comeback with just that but
unfortunately size of lens is out of
turn that means rgn uh next one will
actually be tomorrow
who we just saw lose to aka a second ago
right so
rj and tony are going to be coming up
later uh but i do believe the next match
that we have in the loser bracket is
going to be coffee prince versus maru
however we do got to take a short break
guys short break check an online style
2021 uh gonna be continuing after we
tell you more about the social that you
can follow bnd esports at on both
twitter and youtube plus don't forget
guys we got tekken on twitter twitch and
on facebook as well make sure you guys
go give them followed all those places
keeps up to date with everything tekken
plus everything esports with bandai
namco
all right and that being said guys we
will be taking a very very short break
but when we come back more tekken action
coming your way stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and boom welcome back everyone to tekken
online challenge 21 for the philippines
and east asia i'm rip here with the kid
himself how you doing kid it's been a
fun night so far we got a lot more
action to come though
and yeah pretty exciting matches that we
have upcoming for you guys to see and
i'm really glad we get uh we get the
front row seats for this one because
later on in the matches today we will
have jules versus ak but before that it
will be uh coffee prince versus ma roo
and before that rip
big shout out to astral right
of course dude after the official
headset and mix amp of the tekken online
challenge always support us you know you
see us here with our astro headsets on
uh basically most tekken streams you see
is supported by asphalt these days right
so huge shout out to astro for
supporting all things tekken out here uh
but as you mentioned we do have coffee
pits coming up that should be a good
match you know we've seen him with that
leroy already putting in some work uh
you know he's he loves that back one
plus two man he's just doing it to
everybody he's like yo 12 frame mid
please say no more
you know what let's see if i can still
do the same thing against maru again
these guys have been playing against
each other for the longest time also so
let's see if you know the same antics
the same strategies can apply against
from the philippines top players maru
back one plus two the coffin breaker
such a deadly move for leroy and now we
have the brackets here also waiting in
the winner's finals is jules versus ak
exactly uh and of course one of this
match gets t-rex uh the coffee prince
maru match of course uh did you say the
movie's called coffin breaker
that's what we call it here of course
i mean it's probably the official name
yeah we call it shotgun so it's just
funny because it's just like
you know you used to get shot
up close right so we've been calling a
shotgun
it's a it's a fitting term because it's
a close range blast right uh oh yeah
yeah it's probably not the official term
so regardless if you get a shot of the
shotgun but you probably can't mean
coffin so it makes a lot of sense either
way
uh but cocky prince maru gonna be a good
one uh mario we have yet to see today on
the street correct
uh yes yes we do and um
you know what coffin breaker might not
actually be the official name also i
might we might have to look it up later
on but yeah whatever whatever worked for
both of us right
back one plus two maru
uh i did uh dm mario earlier and he i
asked him what character he used to use
lydia
and you know if he chooses to stick with
the character for an entire tournament
he will keep using lydia he's been
practicing lydia also and
what do you think of lydia rip
olivia is a very good move you know
she's got that move forward one plus two
uh the political storm move uh that is
just such a good
uh long range punisher right so it just
moves that it's only like minus 10 i
believe for the third and fourth hit so
she kind of just throw it out there uh
and it's like oh did it work did it not
work i'm not really sure let's find out
and i feel like it's a very very
spammable move and usually for me when i
see spammable moves in tekken those
moves that i feel need to be nerfed uh
you know i feel like third and fourth it
they probably should make them more
punishable and block uh but we don't get
lydia and we don't get leroy we get
brian fury from coffee prince and we get
negan coming out of maru
maru you liar anyway negan also really
good i i i've been using negan a lot uh
online pretty fun character uh also you
know copy prince does have a pocket
brian fury but he doesn't feel like
using steve fox he goes for the brian
fear let's see how things are gonna go
here round one
interesting
do you think he expected the negan pick
though
i don't think so mario doesn't really
pull out the negan that much
yeah this is an interesting choice
okay hey
mario trying to get out of the wall
coffee friends trying to keep him there
both players nearly outside nearly
getting rage
coffee friends looking for more mid
pokes not going for a lot of hatchet
kicks but side step two
maru gonna close this one out coffee
prince
round two
that was beautiful i love that the way
negan says boom during it too
hey
he's a big fan of uh wow
he's a big he's a big fan of him he's a
rip fan
he is
he probably liked law
do you think so
yeah i think he means well
oh no you know what for that i i'll
think so too but here we go mario breaks
that breakable wall but coffee prince
gets out of there safely mario does have
racial counter hit one two one down
forward two check
coffee prince dude
i'm not gonna lie that conjet up it
looks pretty good even though it wasn't
you know in a state where you can see if
standing whether it hits or not but the
time will look pretty clean
all right
the first few hatchimals we've seen in
this uh
in this set let's see can coffee friends
continue this trade not in favor of maru
the okie is still there for coffee
prince mario outside of rage also coffee
prince
man this is back and forth right now
tomorrow finally creating a little bit
of face like nope too much space
right back in tomorrow with the lead two
rounds to one here
count ahead counter hit reef was four
gonna carry on to the wall also but just
a bit short he will get them there oh
my goodness
let's go copy fans showing us how it's
done
i feel like mario's probably hitting
buttons there but doesn't matter
cockerman's quick answer back final
round game one
conference looking warmed up with the
brian fury
[Music]
right now struggling to find a single
opening for copy friends and he's been
punishing he's been poking about so well
sidestepping everything for copyrights
working out
oh my goodness not that though
there we go maru
bringing it back has a life lead now
back waffles to abuse the plus braves
but he contests he can test the floss
frames from negan and maru takes game
one big mistake from coffee prince
huge and like in that situation why
would you think he wouldn't press a
button maybe i'm not sure what he was
thinking that would be coming instead
for the pressure uh but unfortunate
situation for coffee prince you know
earlier i was saying i wanted to see him
run through the bracket with leroy see
if we can get a leroy to win the
tournament uh bring out the brian fury
here and brian obviously a very strong
character right now as well we saw he
has taunts ready to go as well uh
unfortunately you know just swing at the
wrong time that really cost him uh and
maru with the negan pick probably caught
him a little bit off guard
and a coffee prince is kind of known for
pressing on certain situations where
you're not supposed to press mainly
because it catches the throws off guard
but
this obviously it wasn't uh wasn't one
of those cases it did not work out well
for him so he might go for a switch here
probably most likely the leroy i'm i'm
really hoping for the steve though
interesting okay uh you know you said
you've been using a lot of negan lately
is steve one of those characters that's
kind of a hard match for negan i've
heard that characters who have like a
magic four are difficult for negan to
contest uh but maybe steve you know with
the back one it's a similar situation
personally i think characters who can
sidestep well are really good against
negan because negan is linear as all
hell uh
he he does have a few moves that track
like back to maybe even like side step
two but that's pretty much about it his
back one one plus two his best plus
frame move is linear so you know that's
gonna be that's one of the difficult
parts about negan but coffee prince does
stick with the brian
oh my goodness
what
[Music]
low parry though
mario is just looking sharp unlockable
set up
okay yo this
yeah for sure coffee prince again
looking a bit lustered here maru taking
that wave of momentum in round one
oh boy
counter down four three this time
all right conference got married to the
wall here taunt jet upper no-go
okay oh god yeah
yeah he didn't believe enough
yeah that was a really odd exchange
after getting the launch with the jet
upper
but regardless confidence on the board
at the round count tied now beautiful
duck on the high string but man the
cobbles are dropping for coffee prince
right now
oh maru you can see that he's abusing a
lot of these ff one plus twos because
he's been getting caught by it probably
prince though counter hit f3 going to
see the wall
pop
todd
man the top that's not working right now
the tiniest of pixels
did he try delayed hopkins
i think he did yeah i think he was
trying to get the ticket coming through
maru though again
we cannot count him out topic
one two four punished good perfect
punishment
yeah that ten frame is one of the best
in the game
but man coffee prince like to hit some
buns right now
yeah
he's on fire with these buttons and he's
not stopping again against the likes of
maru he does have him up against
the wall bounce cutting next and here we
go what's the mix up going to be oh try
to go for the no time get up
yo he tried to parry and the bat came
out right then too
[Music]
okay no too far barely barely misses the
punch
just walking back
back and now that was tight not the
punish
yo
set point for maru now coffee prince
facing elimination again backswing start
of the round
the carry to the wall now has him the
pressure is on mar with no exceptions
coffee prince half health we're only 10
seconds in 13 frames punished good maru
with the blocks again coffee prince with
the challenge and maru takes it against
coffee prince eliminating it from the
tournament two to zero
out of here coffee prince goes down
without trying the leroy out and yet
again
we don't see a leroy that far in the
bracket man what's going on i thought
this character is supposed to be so good
kid you know i'm just saying
uh leroys aren't winning
results based tearless let's go leroy no
good uh get him out of here uh but we do
see there the negan coming out getting
the results done uh over brian fury very
nicely done very nicely done
yeah it's it's pretty weird to me how
coffee prince didn't choose to go for
the leroy at that time because leroy
would have i think i think leroy would
have been you know a much better
decision there but considering how long
these guys have been playing with each
other they know each other all too well
so a lot of things have to be you know
switched up there so i think that was an
understandable decision from coffee
prince
yeah and yeah first i just i just wanted
to see leroy you know i just we don't
get to see enough leroys anymore in
tournament uh the character still i
think very fun to watch uh unfortunately
you know brian though also a very fun
character watching you know copyright
put on a show with his brian
unfortunately you know a lot of the top
stuff did not work out for him there uh
and maru that surprised negan picking
his negan looks good you know i think uh
in north america at least we've been
seeing negan kind of make this uh
like it's like a second wave of negan
that's coming through you know the
character first came out as dlc people
like let's try him out you know knee
used him in a tournament and then was
like oh yeah he sucks whatever put him
away but then the character got some
buffs
then the character got some buffs right
they gave the new low everything they
made the down by two safe round blocks
and now we didn't really see a lot of
negan's get picked up but sure enough
now we're starting to see them making
waves in tournaments so it's very cool
to see negan you know kind of uh
flourishing now as the season progress
yeah if if they gave negan um
much better low popes and better
tracking negan would really be top tier
but
we don't want that especially if we are
on the receiving end of that but negan
right now is is it is okay but if he
were given more low pokes rather than
just down four down back four down back
two he'd he'd be a more decent character
than he is now
i think he's fine
i don't think he'll want to give him any
more roles i think so too down back four
counter hit bro that's so that's such a
good situation for him you know i think
he's fine
uh but definitely i think a character
that a lot of people don't have as much
experience with you know it's he's been
out for for years now but people weren't
using it in tournament especially right
so you didn't really have to worry about
it like your top a competitor you're
like i'm not going to play against
against the vegan you know like why
would i worry about negan when i got
[ __ ] on leroy and lydia and cooney
mitchell to worry about but now he's
enough of a threat that you're paying
attention
yeah for sure so now we're gonna get
into the match here i believe it is
going to be
tomorrow versus rgn we talked about this
earlier
does have a noctis
street fighter versus final fantasy
incoming year at the tekken online
challenge 2021 top eight akuma versus
noctis not a matchup that i get to see a
ton uh but it sounds pretty cool to be
honest did the fireballs and his like
his uh i want to say he's kunai do they
do they trade or they just go through
each other does he teleport through the
fireball like i don't even know what
happens that interaction
they go through each other but the thing
is noctis still rolls towards his enemy
so i i don't think if he hit her up yeah
whatsoever
no he doesn't i want to see it oh okay
okay i'll be sticking with oh boy he
wanted to find out himself orders a bait
all right that down two it's so good
it's gonna happen
yeah
oh my god
again another low parry from summary
roof falls up the console oh he misses
the fm
coming in rgn gets finished off
the perfect nicely done tomorrow
looking really clear the knockouts you
know sidestepping or backdashing out of
the way up to get a kick there uh just
so smart just let it wear got the
perfect aura there
and just really looking sharp in this
akuma match-up
up
up forward once it works like a steve
back one pretty good i love it
is it up for not back right you can do
it like in multiple directions i think
it's a weird move because i don't know
which way to call it ever
yeah yeah appreciate you doing this up
back one two
oh god i never knew that but hey the
more you know
okay yep nice try go for low spear and
you know that time the highest rate rgn
he's ready for it let's go
on the board here
all right uh tomorrow been on fire with
these low parries lately and now he's
gonna go for the okie combo oda coming
in there's no way akuma can punish that
unless it's a point black rage and he
can get the ff2 one in
yeah that seems really hard to do
and you know the other thing you know i
think tomorrow we're seeing a ton of low
praise now just because of the last that
we saw with him versus ak right he's
like i can't believe i got hit by a
billion lows i'm low pairing everything
from now on
you know he's looking for a low parry rj
is getting scared at this point oh he
didn't go for it
hey
not i'm here to make that hurt more but
the down four is a good follow round
four
there it is rgn taking it to a round
three he's potentially one round left
homer you've gone back to such a good
move for noctis
yeah it's ridiculous
especially on the internet
get the combo conversion
stop no
no ender but it kind of leaves them out
of rage so it's not actually the worst
drop
dunk and something and something about
it is also that something about this
matchup is when rgn recklessly jumps oh
my goodness
the running oneplus 2 catches our damn
off guard so yeah back to the point that
if rgm
jumps tomorrow
yeah that's probably why he picked the
noctis specifically right because he
knew he was going to be going against
the kuma here
oh man look at my damage those
downforces
oh oh
combo conversion beautiful keep it
simple docked by rgn follows up with the
combo but he misses the hadoop again i
wonder why is that
i mean it wasn't gonna do too much but
again the drop works out leaves him out
of range but this could be enough
and it is rgn round one against tomorrow
so a lot of hiccups from tomorrow there
you know um uh
i i personally think he liked a lot of
offense but rgn just capitalized on
whatever there was for him
with them with the meters and all he's
used them to his advantage pretty good
yeah i was actually surprised it really
looked like tomorrow had controlled the
match from the get-go but as it went on
you know rjn just stayed consistent he's
like all right i've been low-paid a
billion times but you know what i'm
gonna go with these downforce the
downforce really started opening things
up for him uh the combos were hitting
this time you know we saw a lot of the
combat drops from the fadcs earlier but
this time all the comments were coming
together he missed a couple of the
enders but really as i mentioned they
were kind of good to miss because it
left not just out of rage you don't have
to worry about the rage drive hitting
you randomly when you're full speed
expect on the infinite stage
uh so those drops actually were kind of
beneficial
yeah taking a page out of ak's book you
know rgn
down four after count four after down
four he knew he was effective against uh
you know he knew it was effective in
that 8k versus tomorrow match
and now he's doing it himself and fun
fact rgn actually trains a lot with uh
with ak
back when you know the things were still
normal around the world they're
training buddies uh as you call it so
we can we can we can see a lot here so
let's see if rgn can keep it up
whoa okay the king coming out this time
for tomorrow we've seen a bunch of
characters today is this the fourth
character we've seen from him i feel
like it is uh but i'm excited to see
this king
versus akuma
should be an issue when i have yet to
see his king so i'm excited to see when
we bring to the table here
let's see if tomorrow can stay in the
tournament this is losers bracket action
top eight
here at tekken online challenge
philippines and east asia
wow that was so cheap man he's a power
question come on
we all saw it here we go rgn's got the
momentum already we're only 10 seconds
in tomorrow was put in rage and rgs only
got one more mix-up until he can take
tomorrow out in this round one down
three seven golden letters
perfectly gold that time you know
tomorrow started the first game off for
the perfect rg and answers back game two
round one
oh my gosh should we go for a double
perfect
we might are we gonna see a god match
here potentially oh dude you can't save
that early
[Music]
bounce again here we go
uh oh right now
14 golden letters are we going for it
are we going for god bad jump no jump oh
my god we might get a gun oh god man get
it out of here get it out here you got
me all excited kid
i mean it would have been perfect i mean
you were in that one match where it was
a perfect you know
three perfects in a row but tomorrow
does have rgn is this going to kill
no no wall
punish up
all right tomorrow time to bring it all
the way back now
you gotta duck those man i'm telling you
one of these days he's gonna block him
but rgn closes it out three
two oh sweep and eliminates tomorrow
again here we have rgn proceeding to the
bracket amazing performance by rgm
exactly very nicely done there the
double perfect to start it off you know
anytime you do that to an opponent
tournament they are broken uh right and
you know there was a chance you know
tomorrow gets that round you can turn
everything around still but it's so hard
right like everything is stacked and
gets you momentum wise uh rough start
there for tomorrow in game two and
really cost him out of tournament fifth
place that's a great showing uh but
congratulations rgn making it into the
top four here today
yeah and you know as what the filipinos
would say
which means he's he's being so hot right
now that's you know he he
rgn against
so hot i i i can't express this yeah
he's playing so well and he's so close
to the losers final he might potentially
even get to the grand plan this year i
can't wait for that to happen but
we do have we do have to go through
another loser's bracket match which is
going to be t-rex
versus mario
yeah i'm still thinking about like
that's saying uh you know we have a
saying like that in america too it's
from zoolander you know that hansel he's
so hot right now you know that's what
the saying is but
uh maru versus t-rex gonna be a good one
you know t-rex didn't really get
anything started right uh when we saw
him in the winter back in earlier maru
though was looking pretty darn good with
that vegan so
we'll see what character oh that's a bob
sorry uh i'm curious to see what
character we get out of them
uh
when it was t-rex versus jewels it was
bob for jewels and t-rex for the eddie
and then maru with the negan so
maru might go for a character that picks
that picks up relax dance more or even
hands that uh handstand so what do you
think are the options here i'm thinking
maybe he'd stick with the negan maybe in
libya i don't know
i'm hoping we get to see some lydia on
stream uh you know like the negan
obviously worked out well i haven't seen
a lot of negan versus eddie so i don't
know like specifically vegan is good or
bad in that matchup uh obviously
intimidating stance low counter could be
interesting but unlikely uh to see it a
whole lot there
so personally i think lydia would be fun
to watch i'm curious to see how she
handles relax as well that's not a
matchup i've seen a ton of either so
either way whichever one maru decides to
pick here it's going to be fun for me to
watch
yeah it's especially for surprising to
me the fact that we haven't seen enough
lydia's here distributed considering how
uh how much representation we've been
getting from lydia in you know in in
recent tournaments that we've been
seeing for maru though he will choose to
go for the fakum rum into the island
hair guys and t-rex sticking
with the eddie
very very interesting here [ __ ] rob
coming out
uh and you know this character he's he's
very versatile right he's got a ton of
options in every situation i feel like
uh we have not seen at least today in
this tournament uh the pokemon player is
going for any kind of guard breaks
especially at the wall right so i'm
curious if we'll see something like that
uh especially against eddie right
because eddie i would assume on reaction
if i'm going against pokemon when i see
that garbage coming i'm going relaxed
i'm just looking for that at the wall so
i can go relax and punish
yeah i mean what what better place for
you to relax in the island paradise you
gotta you gotta chill out man
relax have a good time
beautiful conversation from margarito
oh my gosh
what what
yeah a little weird there
what that tells me that mario doesn't
have a lot of experience in the matchup
beautiful beautiful
i doubt it though because maru's
training partner is the best eddie in
the philippines who is have fun
so i don't mean to get the character
yeah i meant it was specifically with
pokemon against eddie
oh yeah okay okay that makes sense
here we go maru though up against has
t-rex up against the wall pressure is on
t-rex not looking
all right all day that's what i'm
talking about
yeah back to three from eddie is so
annoying
tomorrow
he really just takes control right he
doesn't seem to care
like what the momentum is feeling like
it's like you know it's always my turn
yeah the thing about that could have
been a lot worse the back two string the
back two string forward eddie is that
it's near impossible to fuzzy the
the second the high and or the mid so
you know that's difficult
yeah maro just in total control so far
t-rex is trying to make something happen
though
down four chopping away
more running three pressure right now
plus nine after plus nine maru's been
abusing that move good block on the low
no proper follow-up but it doesn't
matter three rounds straight
for maru exactly t-rex here in the
losers quarter finals
and that's what i was saying right like
the the appropriate faults in those
situations like it doesn't seem like
with focus he has the right answers and
i know he's destroying the flareon's
eddie that he knows he gets an option
but it looks like he's always not
picking the correct one of the pokemon
which is why i was saying earlier that
it looks like this specifically matches
you know pokemon for him versus eddie
he's having a little bit of issues but a
little bit of issues or not you know
that looked uh pretty dominant for his
father mom
oh for sure and you know eddie might
considering what we saw earlier for
t-rex he might go for a walled stage um
i'm not i don't quite remember what
stage he picked i think it was island
paradise also
but in this case i think and i think an
infinite stage would work better for
eddie but you know every it it depends
on different players right what they
want right
exactly some players they just don't
like having an infinite state they just
always want to have walls you know
personally uh i feel like yeah i've seen
some players talk about how infinite
stages is like classic tekken you know
just the way they want things to be yada
yada but tekken has had walls longer
than it's not had walls you know at this
stage of the game uh walls have been
around since 2004 uh with tech no before
that sorry i was thinking about checking
five walls around tech and forward so
walls were around and tekken for like 20
plus years and infant stages were only
around for like five years so you know
walls are definitely more classic tekken
uh it's been around for a minute
but here we go infinite stage you called
it out correctly there eddie infamous
stage definitely seems to be
the stage of choice fight for any
players
yeah that's why we're gonna see a lot of
back dashing the back dashing man for
sure maruto gets blocked on the down
back four perfect punch by t-rex down um
while standing 1-3
beautiful timing that was a risky timing
there to get a kick but he got the
counter hit on it very nice
and mars gonna have to be careful with
these down back floors
all nearly all of his lows can be
punished with a launch by eddie here so
gotta be super careful about his
decision-making
yeah fortunately you know there hasn't
been a lot of lows that have been lost
but here comes the running three
pressure again from maru
being real cautious right now
wow okay i like to make that for the
raid drive but t-rex doesn't bite time
winding down here
good block no
but no punish five seconds left don't do
something
oh it's over this is t-rex's round right
here and good choice i'm just
staying on the ground
one round for him
exactly staying on the ground that
situation just side roll some of the
hits maybe try to side roll you'll burn
in a clock
so t-rex finally on the board here and
mario had a couple of opportunities
there right
i just didn't pull the trigger correctly
nice low ferry here from t-rex
been dealing with the loads of pokemon
very well
yeah a lot of maru's offenses is stopped
by t-rex's ability to punish the lows
with a launch so you know mars gonna
have to be really careful about this go
for more mids conditioning with the mids
and then go for the lows after but if
right now it's not working though
because t-rex does have the momentum he
does have the life lead mars trying to
catch up with the life
oh no
huge counter hit maru
not going to put him in a ranger and
timeline down here mario small lead this
is not where he wants me i feel like
lifeless advantage t-rex knows what to
do better
five seconds does he get a mix no mix
good defense maru
round three the fact that he pressed on
that one split second would have been so
scary because he would have gotten hit
by that low launcher so scary but maru
takes it one round piece anyway
yeah i feel like the jump over that he
had was crucial
and that second round but beautiful
loper here interesting choice for the
commonwealth maybe you wanted to flip
over at the end not quite deep enough
[Music]
magic 4 combo beautiful the magic four
follows it up puts t-rex atherage now
mario does have a huge
life lead here though t-rex is now going
to try to open things up with lows more
hopes but what can he do against a beast
like [ __ ] rum
yeah that standing three's gonna be out
all day yep there it is again
i mean eddie of course not known for his
sidestep and that standing three
just so much range to keep out there to
close out a round with picks like that
that's gonna be a disaster
so set point now for maru
again the running knee has been
terrorizing t-rex the plus nines after
plus nines he's consistent with those
and now he's gonna continue on the
aggression maru what can he do
and i've lost my feed
so we're going to come back to that
match up when we can uh we'll see what's
going on with that one guys but
hopefully we can get back to the action
in just a second i was standing i was
like uh is that just me i wasn't sure
for a second but mario did have the two
rounds to one lead there over t-rex uh
we'll see
you know what ends up happening there
because obviously he also had the game
lead so it could be uh it could be a 2-0
there and mara could be advancing into
our top four
i feel like i've been this i feel like
i've been in this position before rip
and i don't like it but
oh really
i mean it's my first time here you know
i feel welcome now you know until this
moment i didn't feel like i was
commentating on a philippines event
online you know but right now we're
starting to feel like we got it check it
online challenge i mean we know what
we're signing up for right i mean
obviously the philippines known for
having a lot of uh you know isp issues
uh so we get a lot of issues with
players trying to connect from different
regions and different isps etc so you
know it's it's not uncalled for it's not
something that we didn't expect going to
this uh but it does turn out guys i can
give you guys an update maru did win the
set 2-0 uh the game we did a lot at the
ending of it so we did find that out uh
but mar will be advancing the bracket
yeah and on on the bright side there is
a silver silver lining to this we are
gonna get into our next match
which is going to be jules versus ak now
guys i know you guys have been waiting
for this for the longest time now
and we're gonna have it in just a few
moments we're just gonna sort things out
on our side here make sure you sit back
relax get a few snacks in we're just
gonna bring you more second action
coming your way guys
i love snacks of course guys uh with
mario winning i said that does mean that
we have our top four uh squared away as
you just mentioned uh the winner side of
things will be jules versus ak loser
side we do have rgn versus maru so that
is the four players left in this
tournament guys they are battling for
those regional points so they can make
those regional finals uh as tasty let's
say points are on the line right and
that's what it's gonna be about these
guys need to try to qualify here so that
they can make it uh into that regional
finals
yeah for sure
right so i do believe we can take a look
at the schedule here and here are all
the match events coming of course guys
right now if you guys are watching it's
october 2nd right we're the philippines
in east asia we got a ton more
tournaments coming though right just
tomorrow you're gonna have oh man i hate
saying this word can you save the one
right there region 12 for october third
week
well for october 3rd let me see here
that's uh
oceania
is that how you say it
i i think i can't say it
how do you say
my my american brain says oceania which
doesn't sound right so i hate saying
that word
anyways check that out tomorrow
and then the following week we got korea
and japan
you guys are going to want to check that
out and of course you got the regional
finals coming up after that immediately
after that right we got weeks and weeks
of tekken action taking you throughout
the rest of the year uh all the way to
the beginning of january i see the chat
i'll say oceana oceana oceania oceana
i'll go to oceana all right thank you
chad oh [ __ ] yeah
i don't know uh regardless i mean you
guys have seen me wearing this cool
shirt see this i wanted to see coffee
prince go all the way right i'm repping
my leroy shirt out here right and if you
guys are into getting shirts like this
you guys can head on over to 10-0 gg
slash merch we got the nina williams
shirt the paul phoenix the king and the
martial law are back in stock we also
got the cute ass tekken church you know
the double chibis you got the nina and
the ammo you got the king and the armor
you got the leroy and the sugar plus you
got the julia
and the chang right we got tons of shirt
for you guys so if you guys are
interested check them out 10-0 dot gg
slash merch or if you guys are fancy you
guys got a bunch of technology in your
phone scan that qr code get in there and
you'll get into the website so you guys
can place your orders and get those
t-shirts a lot of these are very limited
we have sold out in the past so if you
guys do like some of these shirts make
sure you guys grab them further out of
your size
yeah i gotta copy one of those those
look sick rick can you show that uh can
you show that to us once again let's see
how it is
uh for real the leroy one there it is
ladies and gentlemen that's how it looks
like in real life cop yourself one of
those courtesy of 10 no shout outs to
you guys thank you so much for uh
helping us out with this one and big
shout outs to you the viewers out there
who are supporting us b and e time no
tenno media and shout outs to astro as
well guys thank you so much for the
support we really appreciate
exactly guys so we're still uh figuring
out everything getting back to lobby set
up so we can get our top four back
underway
but currently of course we do have our
players squared away uh it's been a
crazy night so far right like ak been
looking really ridiculous with that
shaheen uh you know everyone actually in
this top four has been looking pretty
ridiculous the akuma from rgn's been a
lot of fun to watch as well we also got
maru looking really good bringing out
both the negan and the [ __ ] rom now
and losing brac like who knows what
character he's going to bring out next
and of course we got jewels chilling in
the winter's final like we saw him at
the very beginning of this top eight
right but jules been chilling out here
he's been handling it he's just been
waiting he's like give me my opportunity
let me get ak bring on that wingspan
give me a first of three with this man
uh so i'm really excited to see what
happens there that's obviously going to
be the next one we have coming your way
jules versus aka the winner side of
things did you see the bracket it's been
crazy so far uh it's been a lot of fun
and i can't wait to see how things end
up here
yeah and rip i know you've been watching
aka compete for uh you know for such a
long time now already even in even back
in the days when he was still a paul
plus lawman back in tekken tag too can
you shed some more light on that and how
you've seen this kid play when he was
still so so young
i remember you know prior to that i feel
like it was before tag two even where
you know i heard people saying like dude
have you seen this kid from the
philippines martial i'm like i'm the
best law in the world who was this kid
right and then i would hear about him
and then i saw him play and i was like
yeah he's real good
i don't know i don't know if i can hang
with that kid and then unfortunately you
know we never got to like meet up and
play to each other you know back when
like you know i was still decent so you
know we never i've never got to play
them but i i don't think i actually
don't know if i've ever played ak
uh which is crazy surely i've played ak
somebody must have
somebody must have seen this somewhere
right i've lost ak somewhere i must have
shortly uh but i would i would love to
play him still uh but i really do miss
that he left mom you know like i
understand why right shaheen is just the
simpler easier more damaging version of
law right so i understand why you would
drop the kick i just miss it right why
is so much cooler than shaheen uh it's
of course right like who would disagree
with that law is so much cooler
uh but yeah i mean hopefully hopefully
one day ak will find his way back to
martial law you know
in fact you know maybe if he's ever
feeling like he's losing a tournament
and it's time to give up maybe it's time
to pick that martial law you know that's
all i'm saying pick that martial law put
him back at the top of the result space
to your list you know okay we need you
to do it because no one else is doing it
you know um i don't want to bring your
hopes up but in recent tournaments aka
if he didn't feel like playing shaheen
he has been pulling out the law quite a
bit and this gets crazy right he pulls
out
he pulls out the parry and then does the
ford oneplus 4 i don't know i don't know
what you call that move but it's a
guarantee um it's yeah i know i don't
know how it works but ak is such ak is
such a different kind of vlog that i've
seen in
my years of playing tekken and the fact
that those words are coming out of your
mouth also as a la main gives him a high
regard as well so yeah for jules what
have you heard from jules so far have
you only heard him from like icfc or
whatever
yeah very little out of tools to be
honest yes i've seen like his icsu
results you know he's always at the top
whenever he's entering there so it's
always fun to watch duels right uh and
but like in regards to like you know i
think the the world view of the
philippines right you tell people hey
jules is playing ak everyone's gonna oh
ak's gonna win right like it's not even
like a question to most people like when
we do this poll here in a second and the
chat gets to make their predictions and
spend their channel points and determine
who they think is gonna win i can almost
guarantee it's gonna be very highly in
favor of ak right uh it's just that that
popularity factor because he's been
around so long and he's you know
implanted his name in everyone's mind
and we just saw the way he started today
he's been looking ridiculous he's
looking clean you know it doesn't look
like he's having it off there i think
we've seen some of those in the past uh
he's looking sharp today so it's really
gonna be hard for duels here i really
hope they can make something happen
though because i think that would be
real hype
yeah and it's such a cool story to tell
when you
when you associate jules and aka
whenever they go up in a match ak has
always been in jules's way when it comes
to winning tournaments when he so close
to winning the tournaments now right
always gets joe's always gets a second
place jules gets so close to like one
round away and then aka takes it back in
a comeback that's uh that's what's been
stopping jules but now he's been
training a lot more he's been you know
he's been more healthy with his mindset
coming to uh uh trying out new things
and now he's winning against ak even
more and sometimes even super
convincingly so that's how much jules
has been improving against the top
player the philippines ak and you know i
just can't go over the fact that we're
going to see them later on in a best of
five
that's pretty wild right you know tell
me a little bit more about jules like
when when would you say jules really
started breaking out like when was the
time when he kind of made a name for
stuff like i'm forced to be reckoned
with here in the philippines
i can't say for certain when that was
the time that he really made a name for
himself
quite frankly because also i'm me i'm
relatively new to the to the tekken
community as well i've started taking
tekken seriously like around what 2018.
um
i i only heard about jules because of
pika his brother because we're also
coming uh he's also a commentator he
tells me that's my brother he's jews
he's got good defense and that's what uh
that's what he that's the only thing
that he told me right i'm like okay i
might need to know more about that guy
and he showed me and
and he showed me and you know what i got
convinced that's probably
that one match that i saw from him in
this one tournament
and that was an apology wow he's one
he's one of the best that was around
2019.
okay so just a couple hundred right not
not a crazy amount of the eye
yeah that's awesome yeah because i feel
like for sure this
obviously i feel like in this time
period right this uh this weird
training arc we have called covet online
you know a lot of players are like
rising right and the players that are
focused in this past year and a half
which is almost gonna be two years due
i feel like the players that have like
improved in that time period are going
to be the players that are really the
players that are doing well going
forward in the future when we get back
to offline events it really always seems
to be the case
all right and it looks like we are gonna
get inside the match here ladies and
gentlemen
we have the winners finals it is going
to be ak versus jules in the infinite
azure jules immediately with the gen
pick i rip something i want to tell you
right now get ready for jules now he
blocks something if he blocks a load
that's -13 he will crouch cancel into
switchblade i guarantee it
but what
yeah
crouch cancel two four
let's see it
i love gym players you can do it i've
seen daniel mata do that as well
[Music]
but all right the slides coming out
early from the ak
yeah enforcing the lows already jules
though lower than half side step down
forward two ak can he close this one up
perfect yes he will
surf it out perfect ak
what a way to start off the winner's
final here
break his legs
do it again
he's going to by the way
there's no need for us to tell him
because he will he will do it all right
aka trying to go for more aggression
here the slides one after another
oh
that caught him there hold me attack
interesting choice there no sir
all the way off axis
[Music]
this time
no i don't think it's going to come out
any time soon but iggy going to keep him
in check with the downpour he won the
mid
jules also he's trying to sidestep into
hopkick but ak has such a different
timing
hey wow what a good crap that's one
all right beautiful on the slide there
it is jules with the first block on the
slide and now aka
one hit away jules
goes for the safer option down four
again now he's showing some signs of
light
this is what he needs to do right at
least get one round of the board
that way even if you lose the game just
like a little bit of like hope in your
mind
okay now though just with the ankle
checks
preventing jewels from moving
beautiful how does he do it right
again it's the timing man this kid's got
different timing goes for the full combo
jewels lower than half health 35 seconds
left tries to go for a little pokes but
he's got to get more than that but ak
again with the launcher
yeah he had the side step two right
there or the side step into the down
four or two and a lot of times the down
four twos that ak has they're they come
out of the frustration he's putting into
the players right like you saw there a
bunch of just the generic downforce just
to frustrate the opponent and then when
the force frustrates like dude i'm tired
like every time he comes in it gets a
little poke and it's just the first race
thing it's not even doing that much
damage right he's only lost like maybe
10 15
but then they get impatient they rush in
and the nick is like i'm just going to
do a safe downpour too you know it's got
a good hitbox out there if you try to
run into anything here my timing on this
as a keep out tool is going to prevent
you from getting in on it and so it's
just really threatening the opponent
into being too offensive uh and it's
always paid off he's very very good at
the strategy
yeah and also another another fact about
uh jules is that jules has been around
with ak and dojin even before the pro
season so this these guys have been
playing even
before they became legit uh is what i'm
saying that's awesome you know
these guys and girls have grown with
each other they know each other so well
and i think that's beautiful you know
it really is no of course anytime you
have people that you've trained with
your whole life uh to finally like you
know sometimes you'll see some players
excel earlier than others right so
finally to see like your other friends
kind of you know catch up to that level
and like meet you in the winner's final
of a tekken online challenge you know
that's amazing right so shout outs to
both these guys but right now you know
only one of them could win the
tournament uh we're gonna see who's
gonna get into that grand finals a case
ahead one to zero this is a race to
three best of five in this situation uh
we're going to dwell more this cereal
for game two and you'll sticking it out
with jin kazama
yeah here we are at the one with the
studio this has been jules's go-to pick
also recently from
geometric plane
to uh normal cereal a lot of uh
interesting choices here for jules
damn he triple pumped that slide very
nice
made him think about it a few times
god wow look at that he blocked him and
then he fade punished with the standing
f4 wow okay aka that was really good now
has the momentum here we go down four
first one
breaks the throat
oh my gosh
that was it was so risky to even try to
attack once ak did the empty jump uh
regardless duel swung in it worked out
because he could try to look like a
delay hopkins afterwards
uh but jules on the board here
very common calculated both of these
players down three folks coming for ak
jules gets hit gets clipped by the
orbital heel and this should close it
out ak takes it one round a piece
[Music]
and that was a crazy round that orbital
from ak is deadly man
he makes people check their ankles so
often that everyone wants to duck
against them and that's a better option
you know throw out the hop kick you know
let him punish you but at least he's not
doing these lows to you anymore
dude
that's the way to step too right
of course yeah decide them right there
and you know that that's one of jin's
weaker side you got to be careful some
of this up there but
the down four twos are paying off and
you know jules not an electric happy
chin player right like you're not seeing
any electric wind hook fists or any kind
of like 50 coming out of the forward
fours are here and those ones you can
size them right
yeah oh magic four connects ak catches
him with a counter hit and now jules is
in big trouble has to make the right
guess here
what the hell is to catch a movie look
at it again again the side step right
down four two it's there every time for
a wall carries good
the damage shut the damage
that is an unfortunate situation to be
in for jules and ak makes the right
choices over and over again now he's up
two games and jules has none so far this
is a lot of momentum for ak rip
it's a problem for sure uh you know
jules has other characters right like
it's not just this gin uh
i think the bob might be a better choice
here
you know what i don't even think i don't
even know what the right choice is at
this point i i just love seeing these
guys go at it with their names and
playing at the highest level of tekken
possible as possible as they can this is
just amazing to me this is actually just
you know good ass tekken for me
right now i mean the the problem is
obviously the side stepped down four
twos right like ak's catching them for
the time and time again uh and of course
you know aka he likes to set the tone of
the match immediately right he comes out
there he breaks your ankle a few times
or he comes out there he'll slide a few
times and just to get you made just to
make you think about it because everyone
knows ak's play style you know that no
makes a mix of strategy so they're all
scared of it right as soon as one of
them hits so he doesn't have to do a
bunch of them to implant that thought
into your mind
uh but of course after that you know
he's playing this different game plan
but you're still thinking about the
other strategy and sure enough here out
comes the bob uh so yeah this i'm i'm
i'm kind of happy to see the switch here
to be honest i don't think the gym was
working uh right i like like i said he
doesn't really use a lot of the tools of
gin uh probably because of the way aka
stepping him and he probably has some
history there where he's familiar with
it right uh but bob here definitely a
little bit more underrepresented i'd
love to see how this goes
yeah okay let's see now different
strategies have come into play now that
jules has pulled out the bob but ak will
remain ak will remain the same way he's
playing so let's see how things are
going to go here 15 seconds have been
spent these guys finally gets the duck
in on the 4-1 jewels i'm gonna carry to
the wall no just a bit short
smart stuff and look at this dominant
first round from jules here just dunking
that one high for one string getting the
full launch in that i was reading the
turning point solid first round for
jules here again
jules again so on point with the way
that he's playing right now ak's in for
a lot of hurt this is also so good okay
for jules aka half health goes for the
bet but no gets punished by jules
i love to check the downward one there
solid defense too from jules right now
gotta maintain this life lead don't give
a chance to down forward to you oh my
goodness the risks are coming out and
aka
finds the rage drive
okay the patience yikes aka
paying off so well now what we call
jules here in the philippines he's is
that he's the iron wall defense simply
because of how good he is when it comes
to certain situations he blocks
everything it's so good and ak's
exploiting the weakness the flaws of
that
that's crazy
and ak was just so patient there right
like he was behind incredibly behind the
wall 1021 caught him early in the round
again but despite being so behind he
stayed composed the entire time never
felt like he was behind
but here we go jules again building an
earth another early life lead three
rounds in a row
goes for the okie combo aka half health
goes for the slide in goes for another
will he go for more that is the question
jules right now trying to look for more
openings 20 seconds left ak outside of
race jules has to close this one up
without giving ak rage
just hell sweeping bro
it'll work good
oh god
i don't get a hell of a sweep up
the race drive from aka he's not dead
but time runs out
and ak gets another round back from
behind again
we all knew he's coming but somehow we
all got hit by that too
aka playing so well right now he is on
his way to three owing jewels in this
set ladies and gentlemen we're gonna see
the wall here the king charged he
charges
just gets the steel pedal in good
punished by jules
yeah ak you know he's looking sidestep
there it is that's at the counter head
down for two and he used that dapper too
when aka did the size of right because
you know the downpour two is coming out
from aka that would set point and that
will be that ak
three to zero over duels moves on to the
grand
finals on the winner side of things aka
looking impressive here very impressive
we're already you're shocked the fact
that
we yeah right we're already aware of the
fact that ak is a good player in fact
he's a great player but every time he
wins like this we're still so amazed how
can he pull it off
it's it's the beauty of high level
tekken i i love it i love it
yeah and honestly
it's it's the mental game for ak right
like the actual tekken game it it's not
even as important to the mentor again
he's playing with his opponent because
he breaks his opponent's defense early
and then they're thinking about that the
rest of the set and that like that
hopkin or the always the orbit i think
orbital at the final round there and
that's because of the dimensional game
you play throughout like you're thinking
about these lows all day right and as
soon as you think about the lows boom
orbit hits you here's my full combo now
and now you know you're done because i
broke through the lows early and now
you're eating the mints uh and you know
the side steps are all perfectly
perfectly placed right sized him down
for two sides to rage drive you know
anything he needed he had uh so it
didn't even matter the likely that he
was behind or not he was always composed
like i'll find a raid drive later i'll
find it down for it too later not a big
problem
so always composed very nicely done
yeah and oh my goodness aka
just playing in tip top form right side
steps over and over again and the
downfarters uh the the down forward twos
have been so on point ever since before
this match even started even before you
know even in that tomorrow match and i'm
really excited to see ak in the grand
finals right now ladies and gentlemen
sending jewels to the losers bracket
where he will wait between the winner of
rgn
versus mario
rgn versus maru uh gonna be another fun
one right we'll see what character mario
decides to give us this time uh so far
in this top eight we've seen both the
negan and the pakaram out of him uh so
we'll see which one decides to go with
here against akuma i mean that is the
benefit right rgn you can pretty much
guarantee that that akuma is the one
that you're to be going up against so
you kind of have a choice when you have
multiple characters about which one you
want to fight akuma with
yeah and then oh and we're going to find
out real soon the
yeah the decision is right now so
we have
versus akuma now quite frankly this is
okay for [ __ ] because he is a big
character he can catch the demon flips
with no effort required so
let's see
hm
yeah this is i mean in america we don't
really have akuma players man uh we're
weird out of here we're in america we
don't like using the top yeah dude we
don't have any koopas like we have like
maybe one or two but they're not really
doing so hot uh so you know a massive
like this you think that we would have
seen by now but this is something that i
rarely ever get to see [ __ ] wrong
versus akuma
let me see how he has can he just jab
out the demon flip
with his head we'll see about that we're
gonna find out with his head
no proper punish and rgn gets the
perfect punish in 13 frames maru good
punish also here we go what the what
oh what do you think we're gonna come
out and start
very weird how do we start here
hey hey hey
get patient kick those with the low mix
this time
you know throughout the loser bracket
with pokemon we've seen the mid mix come
out every time that was one of the first
times he's done the low
okay
we're playing it a bit slow right now
rgn running one
is crazy good
what the hell yeah [ __ ] around pretty
good
see always stuck always down back
you heard it here folks duck always
after they dropped the fadc combo
prepare for the drop
as much as you can don't give them faith
it's not even disrespect it's it's
respecting how difficult their combos
are you know like oh wow this is really
difficult you may drop that you know
oh here we go oh no he dropped the combo
again rick what have you done
this i dude it's been like this all
night i haven't done anything
okay mario two runs now rgn looking for
more openings here oh that could have
been his opportunity but he missed it oh
oh one two one four rgn plus nine they
using big trouble for enrage
oh my goodness that could have been it
but rgn gets him with a counter his
double jab into the fabc combo but the
downside of that is he doesn't have the
meter anymore
that's very true here no mirror to work
with
but mario's so patient he gets akuma
right it looks like he has a lot of
experience against his character
oh look out
that's not what you want though
yeah this is exactly wall carries good
here really bad
[Music]
yeah he knew he needed to spend that bar
and he built the meter during the combo
itself that was really smartly played by
rgn but here we go final round game one
only best of three here
good block a block and punished by rgn
now maru's one hit away from getting
rage rgn is sitting so comfortably with
this life lead maru's in big trouble one
more hit could do it gets the whip
punish
rgn takes game one against maru who's
looking so good in the first two rounds
that was a beautiful comeback right and
he was it looked like he was falling
apart a little bit right and the the
game start off a little bit shaky on
both sides uh but rgn once he put the
pieces together you know once he
recomposed himself uh you know when i
said put the piece together i mean put
himself back together uh and recompose
himself you know things really came
together the whiff partner at the end
was fantastic the combo started coming
together uh you know and that was just
really smartly played and i think i
think mario got a little ahead of
himself i feel like he thought he
already had that game closed out but it
wasn't closed out it's never over until
it's over that's how the saying goes and
it's that for a reason a very nice
comeback there from rgn
and that's always a factor right when
you're about to close the game out you
gotta stay on your feet you gotta
you gotta play the game that he always
used to not not be you know not be hasty
you gotta slow it down know that it's
not over just yet and there's still a
chance for your opponent to come back
from this that's uh that's the mental
game right there that's also coming into
play when you're in a match so yeah so
that that might have been the case might
have been the case for maru but let's
see if we'll see a uh character switch
here
yeah i mean that's a that's a great
question i mean what are the characters
does he have other than the negan
he might i mean i'm i'm not banging on
it but he might but you know
[ __ ] that stick it out all day every day
yeah
all day early
focus going to be the character choice
to see
if mario can stay in the tournament here
only first of two games are gin up 1-0
in the set of course
uh this time we're going to abandon
temple so he's giving him his own stage
he's like you know what this is your
stage right akuma i'm gonna beat you on
your own stage round one
uh let's see if that's gonna be the case
because rgn's been on its hair right now
maru
gotta find some opportunities they can
have that he can use for himself
okay now arjun's just standing around
he's just letting maru do whatever
he was waiting for an omnivore jumping
it looked like and he found what he
wanted
big life lead here still jumping at him
now god oh my god delayed hop kick from
[ __ ] rob
all right maru
all right
sidestep by maru so good and rgn does
have access to rage he gets him with a
while standing too but doesn't get the
full combo in 20 seconds left what's the
mix up gonna be ghost for the grab kill
oh my goodness oh my god he did the high
seconds left
oh my god
the i frames weren't there not in favor
of rgn and maru with round one
you didn't have metered ex that dp and
maru does get the round because of it
beautiful conversion now he's gonna
follow up with the full cobble rgn is he
gonna get away from this wall the next
the dp
what's he gonna do
holy moly that was far better not lose
this life lead
dude we're all caught up one combo here
and it could be rj's round but the teep
kick
gonna keep things in maru's favor two
rounds now
uh-huh
oh that was scary he could have gotten
full combo right there but rgn gets him
instead with the demon flip mix-up
and maru
receiving a lot of damage here big boy
privileges
rgs the counter hit again
maru's
yeah big trouble but he's got our gems
back the wall got to watch out for that
ex dp you know that rj is willing to
throw it out
beautiful stop them
oh
wow you stop it stop that momentum right
there i don't like it
now
pay attention he does have the meter
here ladies and gentlemen be careful
maru or he's gonna get full combos in
this case rgn presses on that last hit
maru has to close this one out rgn has
momentum
yeah but he's way behind in life right
now
doesn't spend any meter here doesn't
have rage at either now he's got rage
now can hurt he drops the combo he
dropped it but still in it
doesn't have a meter almost the next
part he's got the bar now
one more good block on the low one more
to finish it out rg and builds up a
meter and takes it to a potential final
round can maru take it to a game three
or will rgn pull an upset
he's got the combo this time here we go
walker he's good
easy wall carry combo here what the mix
doesn't get the bounce caught him
airborne fighting to the delayed hopkins
punish that big time
sidewall saves his life though rg and dp
maru
one more hit one more combo from maru
and he could be done for rgn playing a
bit more safely plus nine rgn guys
it's so dangerous yeah it's got you know
it's coming you know it's coming he
wants one he needs one
there's a bar of meter here what can he
do with it is he even gonna use it maru
is just maintaining his distance he
doesn't want to go up in your face
there it is
and rgn catches him on the approach with
the down three fadc combo and eliminates
maru from tekken online challenge 2021
and moves on to the losers final
that was so impressive both games there
maru had a two to zero round count lead
and rgn brought it back both times very
impressive stuff rgn moving in to the
top three here tonight very well played
oh my god i'm gonna need to count i need
to take a breather off that because i i
was crazy dude my goodness me
oh my goodness but before we get to go
anywhere else guys here is the
leaderboard
and you see it there jules sitting with
that hundred points aka with that second
place at 70. but of course things are
going to be shaken up after this event
here right so if you guys haven't done
so make sure you guys are registered uh
on the esports pace you guys can get
your points listed here as well these
are the current standings these guys
trying to get these points to make it
into that regional finals right the
regional finals can have triple the
prize pool of this tournament itself
right so a lot on the line here
outside of just this tournament by
itself in the first place
yeah oh my goodness guys if you want to
rack up these points make sure you
participate in a lot more second online
challenges we did show you guys the
schedule you want to go you want to go
get them points got to get to the
regional finals make sure you sign up
for these tournaments thank you so much
again guys for the support big shout
outs to astro the official uh
headset and mix amp of the second online
challenge 2021 and make sure you follow
us online on twitter and youtube it's
bme esports for both
and tekken for twitter twitch and
facebook that's tekken guys make sure
you follow us
alright guys but we do got to take a
short break before we wrap up things
here with our top three of the
tournament don't go away tekken online
towns 2021 will continue after this
break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
it's not just our power
it's all about powers working as a team
don't underestimate me
here goes
[Music]
[Applause]
be prepared for anything
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take it
back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
they're
gone we came to save you
you won't be getting out of here alive
even the smallest of sparks can grow
into an inferno i must give precedence
to the task at hand snuffing out your
fire before it spreads across the five
realms
i think you can cut me down
what
those with power set the example
and those without it are forced to obey
i found you at last and i see you came
along as well
dannon witch
i thought i had been doomed to a life of
solitude that doesn't mean i'm going to
stop looking out for you not now not
ever
that can't be look out
right now this thing needs dealing with
what the hell is that
everyone be careful
that thing is huge
[Music]
[Music]
looks like we've got our work cut out
for us
it's not just our power
it's all about powers working as a team
don't underestimate me
here goes
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take it
back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace
once lost
the golden order is broken
to its core
[Music]
[Music]
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
they will fight
and they will die
in an unending curse
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
brandish the elden ring
[Music]
for all of us
and there it was ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to tekken online challenge
2021 philippines and east asia online
masters you just saw the trailers for
scarlet nexus tales of a rise and eldon
ring now personally i'm a big fan of
tales of a rise i played a bit of the
game i i've yet to finish it no spoilers
but rip what do you think
dude elden ring i'm so excited for that
game just looks crazy i'm pretty sure
that dragon has four wings i've never
seen a four wing dragon before but you
know it's it looks like basically an
airplane you know with wings it's pretty
awesome i can't wait and scarlet nexus
that was that game was amazing i would
watch that ad like a couple more times
even that was just fantastic
uh yeah and you know
before we get into our matches we do
want to say our special shout outs to
astro the official headset and mix amp
for the second online challenge 2021
it's what we're using right now it's
great it feels great it sounds great
thank you so much astro for sponsoring
this tournament
exactly guys but we are into our top
three here now uh it's been a wild night
so far aka's been playing absolutely
ridiculous out here uh can we see what
to come but he's waiting right he's
still sitting over there in the grand
finals he's waiting for the winner
between jules and rgn in our losers
final right now so that is the top three
of course we had maru going out of
fourth place in a crazy match with rgn
it was down the wire every time he had a
two-round lead every game didn't matter
rj's like don't worry two rounds that's
not three i'll get the whole game so
first of three rounds of course you know
it's never over until it's over
um but of course that means rj advancing
to that loser's final going up against
jules right now
oh yeah dude it's the epitome of it
ain't over till it's over rgn showing
just showing us how it's done closing
rounds out so let's see what's in store
for us in just a few moments rip take it
away
i mean of course you know even before we
get to
those matches you know i'm wearing the
sick mirror shirt you guys already know
are we gonna see another leroy i don't
know but if you guys want a shirt
similar to this one check out these good
ass tekken shirts from our friends over
at 10-0 you got the nina williams the
paul phoenix the king and the martial
law shirts of course t-shirts were sold
out before they're just limited stocks
make sure you guys get them while you
can we also got the cute ass tekken
shirts the nina and anna don king and
the armored king leroy and sugar and of
course julia chang chilling by her
lonesome so if you guys get some there
again 10-0 gg slash merch otherwise you
guys can use that qr code scanning your
phone get the website that way official
license tech and merchandise if you guys
have been around as long as i have you
know that it's very very rare to come
across some officially licensed tech
emerge so if you guys uh want to support
make sure you guys head on over there
and grab one of those shirts
i gotta copy one of those armor king
shirts and the king and the king one it
looks so good it's sick as well i don't
i don't mean king i don't mean the
jaguars but damn they got the best
looking ones i tell you that right now
so guys make sure you copy copy
yourselves one of those it's worth it i
promise
you promised you heard it here first
folks kid promises you know
is that a kid guaranteed that's actually
gonna get you in trouble here uh but
regardless whether you guys get the
shirts or not uh you know because and i
and i do mean this we did sell out at
the king and the law shirts those are
the first ones that we released uh we
people could not get the size they were
gone for a while they finally came back
in that's why they're available again
now so
if you guys are interested in those
shirts at all now is the time to get
them because i promise you they will be
gone again and
they're probably out of your size
probably you probably have to check to
find out if that's even available to you
uh but yes the matchup that we have
coming up let's talk about this one
right we got jules going up against rgn
of course rgn with the akuma who is
jules gonna use
uh you know what i'm not even gonna try
to guess here but of course goes for the
uh the most comfy pick that he can
possibly get it's the gym so um fun fact
jules's former teammate in omega uh
jason
he you know he used to be an akuma main
so he does have a bit of experience here
and the fact remains that pika also has
been trading with the kuma so jules can
get some experience in so let's see if
jules's training pays off here in game
one
what the heck that didn't reach
that's pretty wild that's the sixth
start of the round strat for an akuma
player uh but you know historically jen
has always been a good character choice
against the kuma just because he can
carry the demon flip options so uh we'll
see how that comes into play here as
this match progressive obviously
if you're playing these characters you
know this matchup and you know it from
both sides
for sure and now jules is trying his
best to keep rgn at the wall here by
sidestepping realigning himself rgn
looking for ff4s but not getting any of
those and jules though playing a bit
more patient compared to what we've seen
him in the past few games
that was a really nice size of left
there but gets caught can we convert the
combo smart
today that he wouldn't have had enough
damage otherwise unless he spent the
rage art there so hit him with the
region dating demon and sealed the deal
first round rgn too
yeah that was super unfortunate for
jules because as soon as he uh canceled
to zenshin stance after f4 he put
himself so close to rgn to the point
that he got the down three opportunity
in so rgn very smart decision making
[Music]
now that put rgn at such in such a
difficult position to be and and he's
also so close to rage right now he
spends his meter jules is outside her
beige now rgn is put there one more hit
tries to go for the dp jules reads it
and takes back round two fight
that was such a stable right just to
stand there and let that dp fly up like
no
not even on my level kid
okay all right let's see if things can
change a little bit here now
luca looking a little bit different this
time around
a lot more scanning pokemon
because of it
goes for the wall carry combo rgn so
posted wall also trying to get away from
it but jules a bit early on the call
there gets caught by the mid rgn drops
to come on the last hit
what time we got that friend kick their
back we're not gonna be enough to kill
backs away back to one again too far
that time
oh
to punish here rgn's just one hit away
jules is gonna compete right choice if
he wants to close this one out he does
he does have meteorology jules
wastes the opportunity to close things
out maybe hesitated for a second there
and rgn tap closes on it and jules is
not happy with it
no sir i mean he overheads hit like
crazy like all you're trying to do is
forward four repeatedly that's a counter
tool it's not like a round ending tool
right and it's so easy to step uh and
you know he had him dash his face like a
single jab keep out might have been all
he needed right so
really unfortunate there but doesn't
matter right now jules big lead but oh
boy i might have spoke too soon
oh my goodness
might have rip
not looking good for jules right now rgn
has rage jules is one hit away from rage
also he gets that down three and rgn
closes it the same way he did tomorrow
rgn with game one in this best of five
set
yeah and you know i was talking about
the parry that jin has in this akuma
matchup
not being used currently right a lot of
the demon flip options are working
a lot of them are landing and you know
jen one of those characters that doesn't
really have to deal with it right he can
either parry or even his magic four is
like the screw attack out of the air uh
so he has a couple of options including
uh most characters do just a sidewalk
right uh sidewalk and block but right
now the defaults are really really
paying off uh for rgn uh you know we'll
see
what changes come this way right now but
it's not looking good for jules the only
good news for him is that this is a
first to three sets this is losers final
best of five the whole way through here
uh so anything can happen we'll see
not over yet yeah there's a lot of a lot
of opportunity for jules to adjust here
a lot of opportunities to also download
uh his opponent
reminder that jules has a lot more
experience in the bag uh compared to rgn
so he might use that experience uh
against him so you know jules might make
the switch here maybe go for the bob
this time uh jin doesn't really look
like it's working out but if if he does
stick with jin he doesn't have the
chance to switch the job if he uh switch
to the bob if he loses
yeah we saw the switch to bob in the
winners final against ak after being
down 2-0 and that at that point you know
it was working but it's too late right
so
uh hopefully the same thing doesn't
happen here
we'll see what he wants to do here
or how he does how he approaches the
matchup
uh if it's so if it's any different from
the way we saw in the first game
let's see what has changed already for
jules goes for more low pokes this time
he realizes that rgn doesn't really
block any of those as soon as i said it
i know right
just to make us look bad
nice punish that time all right canned
cans there for the tatsu wall carry easy
here for gin
[Music]
i think the scariest thing about these
before
yeah that's the scary part right rgn
when he has a life deficit he's unafraid
to just go in right now and jules is
kind of terrified to close things out
and he's always at a full bar here smart
all right round two now that's the
better round strategy i like that
that's true it's it's so risky for jules
to go for a low here because he knows
akuma can kill you with one combo even
if it's a low parry uh so you know jules
is playing this one out more safe than
usual rgn's just taking advantage of
that right now
yeah but once akuma has meter too you
also don't want him to just run up on
you right because the mix becomes a
little bit too scary to deal with that
because a quick down three and you could
lose half your life real fast
nice walking dog rgn
punishes also the sidewall saves this
life though jules good luck on the low
what's the choice going to be rgn f3
closes it up
fight
yeah i'm a little bit nervous the jewels
right now
arjun in the matchup just looks a little
bit more comfortable to me
oh if that was electric and electric but
he missed it by just a bit rgn
try to go for more offense here but
jules so far cannot find any openings
yet
he's trying he's got a spot lightly
though running three no go oh boy
that's huge all right rgn probably gonna
knock him into rage no okay well now
he's got ray that's gonna be enough
damage
calculated there by rgn
and jules struggling
to get the offense in for rgn because
the more he approaches rgn the more he's
susceptible to down three combos
especially the fact that he's already at
another meter good rick punished by
jules and now he's got the momentum and
toe kick does not stop his momentum but
the dp will
yeah in that first game we saw him wait
for it this time rgn
letting it rock and oh here comes the
downforce nice 2-1 check and that's such
a good choice from jinder right like
that's much harder for akuma to deal
with when he's trying to rush it on you
and down three
yeah for sure and jules again has to
take into account the down three and he
has full bars of meter
rg i'm going to carry to the wall my
goodness look at that well no
that could have been way worse he got
very lucky there
down three fireball too far that time
the wall here dashed all the way to get
the full combo beautiful execute from
rgn and that will be a perfect to close
out game number two rgn just needs one
more game and he's going to the grand
finals of the top two finish guaranteed
that's two games straight for rgn in
this best of five set jules has one
more chance
to take this and come back from it this
is not looking good for uh for our iron
wall of defense this jules omega jewels
can rgn make such a dark horse play and
tell this story to all the viewers out
there that he can go toe-to-toe against
the top players in the philippines
that would be amazing right and you know
the one big thing that i'm noticing so
far in these first couple games you know
jules has the life leads right he's had
multiple rounds of life leads and as
soon as that happens in this rage mode
for rgn he's got a little bit of meter
he just starts folks attack dash
canceling forward he's like i'm gonna do
this and you're gonna let me and that's
what's happening jules is letting him
just control the pace of that right
because he's scared and then because you
can't tilt the timing fit the down three
becomes more unpredictable he's finding
the down threes and in that case full
combo extended he didn't need to do the
fadc there right he could have killed
him without the fdc commenting document
he's just done a simple one-time
balcony break then downstairs screw
attack rage whatever phrase right but he
went for the full time he's so confident
right now that's scary right arjun is
playing very loose right now he's very
very comfortable even when he's about to
die each round which is the worst thing
for jules right now and the question
right now obviously he's tried two games
with jim we saw him switch to bob before
does he switch to bob here
you know i i think uh my hunch tells me
that he's gonna switch for the bob
because
if
jin hasn't been working like at all
and jules also struggles with closing
the rounds out he might need to uh give
out the same energy you know give out
the the same type of riskiness that rgn
is playing uh with um with jules's bob
gameplay so we're gonna see that in just
a few moments boys and girls are we
gonna see a character switch or are we
seeing the gin but no marduk instead is
chosen by jules
wow
this is a big switch up and i like it
marduk is a crazy character
uh in this game right now
you know we definitely see him
i don't want to say that he's
underrepresented
but he's definitely better than you
expect
put it that way push guaranteed why who
cares
mixed
away from the wall though here we go rgn
guessing the mix-ups gets wrong and rgn
gets slow buried in obviously wall no we
will not
holy what was that
what the hell
[Music]
all right
maybe just a bit of a shaky start for
jules here now he just needs to close
this one round out rgn throws out the
hadouken
okay down three spends the fadc 10
seconds left jules has a rage rgn gotta
be super careful here what will jules
don't meet him what are you gonna do
what
back up back up oh
all right all right jules on the board
first here held on to a round with the
life lead
nicely done
talking about damage look at martic yeah
not the cleanest round but it does work
here we go jules
immediately
for the well-standing launcher he's not
he's not happy about the previous
results rip he wants them back he wants
them points back
you said not a clean round like watts is
perfect immediately afterwards
oh my goodness everything is landing
counter hit right now get in this air
back this way i don't think so
bro if he loses this round though you
know
i don't think he'll get out of the air
stupid 2d character just a jab
you cursed it
damn man martic is a great choice
embardic is a fantastic i like that
because he has so many just hits that
it's like i'm just gonna throw it out
there and if it hits you fine if it's
not i don't care you know like if you're
concerned about an akuma fad seeing up
to you and around down through you just
throw out a down back too with martic
what's the worst that could happen you
know what i mean you're just gonna hit
counter it maybe regular hit otherwise
they're gonna block it and nothing's
gonna happen you're the same position
you were before anyway uh i like the
kick i like to pick a lot so good stuff
jules
yeah i've seen i've commentated so many
of jules's games already to point out
that he plays so differently uh
comparing it to the gin pick
the martific is so different like
he plays aggressively
but it doesn't feel like it you know you
know what i mean it's difficult to
explain
up until you get to to actually play him
that's what i that's what i mean here
and i think that's what rgn is also
struggling with in that round right now
given the fact that he also has has to
adjust the uh to a new sort of play
style so jules has a really big
advantage here
yeah i mean i think the thing i know
like similar to what you're trying to
say there
i think there's one time where rgn tech
rolled and jules attacked with the while
standing through with mark like on his
tech roll or something it seemed like a
really weird place to put the while
standing three but he just he didn't
want to give up his turn ever he's like
nope i'm going with the big stuff and
i'm not going home with it uh but there
you have it he's on the board now two
games to one arjun needs one more he
prefers the stage not first time we've
seen him pick it
let's see if we can close it out here or
will this martic send us to a final game
in the set
oh there it is on point punished by
jules one two is minus 15 after all the
jewels full damage combo looking forward
spots here rgn's in big trouble
so low in attack right now he tried to
break but doesn't guess right either
jules one round fight
yeah that was the spear version
down still hoping for a jab started
round didn't find it
but here comes the down fours and the
running three for the mix
oh wow what are we punished by jules rgm
catches him with a down jump drops the
combo though uncharacteristic for rgn
here we go jules presses on the third
hit does have rage try to go with the
wind punishing one boy 13 frames oh boy
stop by jules has raged down for to stop
him in his tracks rgn takes it back
i like this look better you know jules
having the life lead and losing to kuma
that one's not worked out for him but
right now when rj is likely then jules
has rage it's terrifying so i kind of
preferred to be that way because jules
wants to win this holy moly that looks
so funky
that's true
okay rgn outside of rage go oh good duck
falls up with the combo though not much
damage gonna get out of this front but
he does build up
some meter though down forward one jules
can he close this out yes he can
jewels very impressive
fight that downford one came out of
nowhere and the momentum as you
mentioned clearly on the side now the
downforce for the whip punish even
blocked the down three
and there goes one bar rj still has the
bar to make this comeback happen though
goes for the stop and the gut kick
jules takes it to a final
game
now this i like to see this is a
different kind of jewels and i love it
completely different this is so much
better for this matchup that his gin was
right and his gym you know it hadn't
really seemed on point right you started
the electrics weren't really there when
he tried to do him he got the windy
versions etc uh but the mark everything
is there right like martin doesn't have
that execution barrier that the gym can
have you having an off day with your
execution you don't got to worry about
that as much as marduk you know uh like
you can hit the wrong button the right
things will come out it's amazing
he's a great dirk
um
and sometimes you do things and you're
like i didn't mean to counter hit that
fantastic you know lo i'm just trying to
low poke boom
exactly what i intended to do i'm martic
i i got a friend who's a mardic man when
he tackles somebody he just mashes the
hell out of one and two and just hopes
for the best i love it
yeah that's amazing it's amazing
that's that dude if i if i was a martic
man that's what i would do i would just
tackle them and i would match the punch
because if i don't know what's happening
you don't know what's happening you know
what i mean how you're gonna break it
you can't read me because i can't read
me i'm just hitting the button
that's the best strategy in your mark
man that's martic mentality right there
martik mentality 101
it's the
the omega male grind set right there
here we are at souk though
rgn
chooses the stage this time the smallest
stage in the game
and it's to be the final game here in
the set losers final who's gonna go into
the top two somebody's going home with
third place here
uh and the martic has been working i'm a
little bit scared for our generation i
was scared the other way around before
but now things have definitely turned
am i gonna root for a coupe over martin
no i don't know i don't think i can do
it nope
very
see it's it's conflicting to a lot of
people in the chat also so don't worry
about it rg endo
trying to be in tip-top shape this is
the final game
what the hell
okay jules eating a lot of these pokes
right now
does have rage this time
rgn up against the wall
there it is rgn closes it up with a down
four
very solid
oh yeah here we go
now we have not seen comments like this
on rg to be honest
like they're like the bread and butter
staples but he hasn't really had a
chance to land them
what a block and punished by jules rgn
again has to guess right here he's he's
always left at a guessing game when it
comes to jules's juices
and that was such a good choice for the
power quest that jules threw out a
second ago right cause he's gonna leave
martin grounded anyway oh my goodness
just get the counter right here to the
wall we go
jules answering back now
i don't know if that grab was
intentional throws out a high and arjun
gonna make him pay here he's got rage
he's gonna have a bar here too
yeah i gotta be super careful here she
leaves jules out of rage also he spends
it no clean hit one more mixer could do
it rg and kenny closing yes he can
potential final round for rgn can jules
come back from this boys and girls
he's fought all the way back it would be
a shame for him to go out here coming so
close but rg trying to steal it trying
to go to the grand finals
even flip palm working out jewels
falling behind but the downfall one
outrages the down four
okay
that's the setup what's the mix-up
doesn't break the throw
what's the mix up here he breaks it okay
good for good for rgn down four after
down four good side step
i'd hold my breath there right now
has to make the right decisions here
no counter at that time too comfortable
right now i don't know what's gonna
happen
[Applause]
round round three to two against jules
and eliminates him from the tournament
and will be meeting ak in the grand
finals congratulations
to rgn
exactly rgn well played you know things
were falling apart to that martic he had
to change things up you know he played a
lot more saw the first two rounds that
got the early lead and he really didn't
let jewels have opportunities to come
back right like that's so scary against
marduk uh and jules you know great
showing as well goes out of third place
here tonight but jules you know well
played you know imagine if the market
started off the set the score may have
been completely different right like uh
the gin just wasn't there for him today
didn't work out in the winner's final
doesn't work out lose final and with
that duels out at third but rgn will be
advancing to go up against ak
in the grand finals here tonight that's
pretty exciting i didn't expect our
generator's parts this is pretty cool
very very good stuff from rgf
and you know big problems big shout outs
to jules also for making it this far
coming so close to the grand finals and
you know grand finals here ladies and
gentlemen ak versus rgn these two have
played uh these two have played against
each other a lot already before and
we're gonna see that again we're gonna
see shades of their training days here
in this grand finals rip let me know how
you're feeling man
i'm feeling great but you know if you
guys are feeling like you guys need to
enter some of these yourself make sure
you guys go on and sign up guys because
we got events around the world right
obviously we're out here in the
philippines and east asia right there
you see us in region 11. but we still
got region 12 kid how do you say it
region 12 that's oceania
what
ocean
something like that uh she got
region 13 to 14 korea and japan coming
up in the next week too so it's going to
be a wild couple of weeks guys and then
of course we have all the regional
finals starting up right after that
going back south africa to kick things
off for the finals all the way down
north america january 9th to close out
the tekken online challenge 2021 so lots
of good ass tekken to come around the
world uh regardless of whatever region
you guys are in uh we got some tekken
for you
all right how are you saying
second action
a lot of people here are just messing
with us in the chat right now it's
oceania it's ocean and
uh oceania
it's something like that oceana i think
it's oceana
is there an eye in it i don't know i'll
figure it out one yeah mostly i don't
know what to do
i'm gonna watch it just to see what they
say you know what i mean that's my
strategy tomorrow you know whenever that
event's happening this guy's going in
so i can study
this guy's got a good got a good idea
right just say ocd
oce
you know that's not bad but it's not
written as oce no one even know what i'm
talking about they're going to read it
like what's that you know
people don't know what that is in the
rest of the world at least not in
america because we're uneducated but you
know oh ocean
that place you know they're they got an
event coming up tomorrow it's exciting
it's down in australia that region
it's gonna be cool
i don't have a lot of killers there also
uh yeah you're out of place there
i mean i don't know if rest is still
full there's what i was really thinking
about but the guy like dion gray uh
who's always been a fantastic player
uh yeah there's oh man they're so great
they got alchemists down there as well
it's very good uh yeah the tournament
down there i'm trying remember that
battle arena melbourne i've been to
twice and that was one of the funnest
tournaments i've ever been to like in
the world right like red major is my
number one actually like you guys in the
philippines have the craziest funnest
tekken fans in the world uh but you know
just like a very chill low-key like very
fun scene is definitely down in
australia i highly recommend that turn
to anyone uh when that you know
eventually gets rolling again basically
uh but yeah terms around the world
offline events are just so much fun you
know i can't wait for them to come back
uh i can't wait to start traveling to
them again you know there was in europe
i haven't really gotten to visit as much
so i'm really hoping to go back to there
eventually but
uh rev major battling the melbourne
those are those are some of the top ones
on my list for sure
and you know it makes me
it makes me really happy that there's
more uh
[Music]
exposure for the philippine uh
philippine second scene right now
because quite frankly we don't get as
much attention uh compared to what achy
got for us back in evil japan so uh this
is this is a great this is a really good
start for us we just need to be
able to travel more frequently more more
tournaments you know big shout out to
you guys thank you so much for providing
this for us it's a it's a great
opportunity so thank you so much
yeah tekken online challenge of course
you know i mean that's kind of the goal
right like everyone knows the world is
kind of locked down right now uh and
obviously the number of regions we just
saw on that chart a second ago uh this
is truly global you know there's there's
tournaments happening in africa uh in
different parts of africa you know all
across asia north america et cetera et
cetera right so uh it's really wonderful
that the tekken online challenge has
given us opportunities to so many scenes
uh literally around the planet but it's
time guys for the grand finals rgn vs ak
ak on the winner side of things out here
sticking it out with shaheed rgm
bringing that akuma you know ak used to
use akuma so you know he's gonna be well
versed in the matchup let's see what
happens
game one
all right so ak
the winner side huge advantage for him
rgn gonna open things up with a down
four we know how effective that was
since the last game aka sidestep into
dash in into altair that's pretty damn
good
that was crazy oh my god god dude
bro
his reactions are insane right like he's
been doing seismic downpour two all day
sidestep delay hopking
as a whiff punish
bro
he's playing next up that is a statement
for the grand finals right now
yeah for sure that is ak second we are
seeing here boys and girls rgn's gonna
have to adjust to that let's see if ak
struggles the same way jules did in that
last game whether or not he can close
rounds out properly again we cannot
count rgn out considering what he showed
us earlier
bro his side step on the down for a
second ago was so incredible
like i was just in awe i didn't say
anything i was like
how do you do that
yeah that's right i'm gonna go for the
wall here big damage coming in from rgn
aka put that rage can he come back from
this down four to close things out here
we
go fight
yeah that's a great sign from rgn right
like ak's first i was so dominant with
these hop kicks and with these delayed
hopkins that it looked like they were
gonna fall apart key charge out of time
still key charge what
that that's wild like i'm curious what
like the best option kuma would be there
i can't care i did it again
oh my god ak is a beast aka
i can't
i can't believe that you can't believe
that ak did something again you know
what i mean if there's anyone that's
gonna do something again it's ak
i never should have doubted it
oh my god ak is such a beast rgn though
still trying to
come back from this almost for that
range here
orbital can he close it out one more hit
our jam looking for the low parry uh
just a bit late the timing was off for
ak
and then exactly what ak did there is
exactly what jules needs to do right
like just throw off your timing a little
bit and then do your low attack right
because it makes it much more
unpredictable like if you just run up
and immediately attack then it's just a
pure 50 50 right like they're gonna
probably fish for like a fuzzy low low
parry low block and stand again but if
you just stand there for a second then
all of a sudden everything's out the
window you're just standing in pure
neutral and then they have to guess
right so smart stuff from ak there get
in that first game and you know he lost
the second round but every other round
was just so dominant uh in terms of you
know his facing and his punishment it's
like he's like are you gonna throw a
fireball because if you do i'm probably
gonna size different hot pick you you
know i'm gonna i'm beside them and kill
you in some way or another uh maybe it
might be a delay hopkin uh so if i'm rgn
i'm a little i'm a little hesitant to
throw out some fireballs after that
first game
and probably one of the most common
round enders also is you know the df1
mid check that's always a thing and the
generic down four yeah you know that was
a good choice for ak because as if i
remember correctly generic downforce
depending on where they came from like
from standing into like
from standing to a generic downfall
that's -13 if i remember correctly but
if it's if it's from a full crotch
that's launch punishable yeah did i get
that right
i don't know about the standing data but
definitely the full crash one is
launched punctual i think the other one
might be a little bit less i don't know
if it's minus 13 actually if it's my 13
i've been punching it wrong for a while
i feel like anytime i block a generic
downfall i always do while standing four
uh so it might be like 12 maybe it is 13
though somebody let me know in the chat
if you guys know
but here we go game two choose an
infinite stage here uh walls are
definitely factored but also switching
characters the devil gin comes out for
rgn
and starts things off with a hell sweep
also fearless that's what we call rgn
right now no matter what the situation
but ak does punish him with a sidestep
into the hop kick ak brings the damage
back
wow finishing laser scraper
i like that electric there
do it again
oh my god he's trying to delay hot kick
on the cover
counter hit into the guaranteed 2-3 ak
so aware of the situation
yeah that counter-head noise that comes
out is so loud like i think if you're
playing with sound like that's such a
big deal to easily counter it confirm
yeah rgn there it is again the hell
sweep but how long how many houses can
he do against guys a guy like ak who can
most likely guess what you're what
you're going to do after uh afterwards
you know
the bigger problem is you can already
see ak is side step left and locking
right he decides to let blocks not have
blocks so if there's a high sweep coming
right he's looking to step in the first
place
one one two puts ak at rage now this is
a danger zone ak pulls the trigger on
the rage art but rgn was just psyching
him out the wave dash block and now one
round a piece
yeah it was pretty behind there pretty
uncharacteristic for me to just kind of
give away around like that
uh but you know he was feeling it
four four over the slide that time
what a sidestep into electric rgn ever
so aware the execution is still there
aka with the orbital again can anyone
count how many he's hit
he's so good at it
because of this right he's breaking so
many damn legs everyone's like i can't i
need my legs and underneath the orbital
these are new shoes man stop stepping
dude
punish that all right rgn looking good
in this game so far health is finding
its mark there
beautiful okay now our
rgn
trying to close this one out this is the
infinite stage some a lot of movement
gonna happen here
akito doesn't even look flustered about
what happened in the last few games
nice block and punish
yeah our jazz devils is looking really
clean
this is such a surprise i didn't know
that he had a double gin but
you know it's kind of cool that he's got
both execution characters you know
okay here we go ak lower than half
health he's a few minutes if he's a few
hits away from getting rage here now he
does good low parry on the hell sweep
now what can you do to close this one
out go for the oaky combo oh boy
hip-hop and ak closing this one out
taking it to a final round
yeah i mean that's really a bad call out
there with that spring kick and just
like that ak now could really turn
things around if he takes a 2-0 lead
here it's gonna be rough for rgn
oh
man and ak really stepping up doesn't
get the delayed hopkins
the pokes are so good it's adding up for
ak and rgn trying to make the right
guesses but he can't he wants delayed
hopkins so bad
yeah he's mighty
he's looking for it gotta be careful
about that level gin rage driving down
down three
ak's so good with that ak so good that
whenever he knows whenever he knows that
his opponent's gonna approach him boom
eat this uh eat this
or boom eat this down green he's so good
with that it's foolproof
that one was crazy because he actually
knocked him away then he did like four
backpacks it's usually a range where
you're looking at the screen you're like
okay there's nothing you can hit with
and ak knew that he gave him enough
space to hang himself so he's gonna dash
and he's not gonna expect me to dash
forward and reach out with his glow
right like he knew the range perfectly
it was a perfect bait closed out the
game there and ak now up 2-0 one game
away from taking the whole tournament
here today
impressive man
i mean honestly impressive today
for sure ak really cementing the fact
that he is the best player here in the
philippines right now there is a reason
why we call him the top player here
alongside jules alongside maru and all
the other pros here in the philippines
guys he's here he's not here to make a
point he's just here to just remind us
all
yeah he's all i mean regardless if he's
reminding you or not like it's always
good to have that player in any scene
that everyone can like strive to beat
right like he is the guy you know you've
got to beat ak to put yourself on the
board so you know all these players that
go up against them it's an opportunity
every single time to make a name for
yourself right uh and as aka being the
defender of that like that's pushing
yourself to be a better player as well
because you know everyone's gunning for
you right uh but here we go forgotten
realm great stage for devilgen as well
uh let's see if it can work on rgn's
favor
uh but you know shaheen is a monster and
ak has been absolutely ridiculous today
absolutely ridiculous
for sure i don't think you know i don't
think ridiculous is even enough to just
cover it all for how aka is playing
right now
argento gets oh gets buried in but he
does get the first uh floor break
wow interesting doesn't even decide to
do a screw attack there
[Music]
okay down back to
ak has him up against the wall oh that
could be so scary for rgn
keeping that he's just staying here
he's gonna look at that power quest
again right
or maybe a delayed hopkin
you know he's looking for it does have
rage here rj's gotta be super careful
here
don't be reckless don't make any mistake
don't whip on rgn did not press a button
yet again
round two man ak's wild dudes
oh my god
start of the round he's here to remind
us he's here to remind us bro
i've seen people online talking about yo
electric for cover too fast blah blah
start of the round delay hop kick the
whiff punish and electric bro that's
where ak is playing right now
oh my god and he lets it rip with the
down back two one also knowing rgn would
press rgn right now
i don't know what he can do here
he can help sleep
yeah more healthy
more floors
okay
oh gosh oh god out of that situation too
rgn was not expecting that now the
aggression is on ak plans on letting him
stay there one one two punish good but
that puts ak in rage rgn now he's been
in the situation but let's hit rip on
the hell sweep now he's up two rounds
all right rgn
can still bring this back it's not over
until it's over
right the devil's is definitely warming
up he's got the round count lead here
the movement the size stage was
definitely a good choice
yeah
rgn picked this stage it's good for
double gin
okay
beautiful kind of a little wave of
action hit back get the insta while
standing out of it got the while
standing too
uh and just like that he's on the board
two to one here it's not going to be a
sweep ak still has to fight to win this
tournament and now you know it gets a
little bit interesting right because
arjun he could still win the whole
tournament you know when you when you
get in the grand finals you this
position like oh i'm up 2-0 you kind of
get the feeling that it's over right but
it's not it's not over until it's over
rj could still literally win the entire
thing which is the funnest part about
this to me uh and honestly the diligent
is looking sharper and i feel like ak is
already kind of showing him everything
that he can do right so now it's all
come down to the mental game uh about
which we've seen time and time again
right like is ak gonna condition him
with the lows hit him with these
orbitals the side steps gonna be up for
the downpour twos are the slides gonna
come back you know there's a lot of
options here it's gonna be hard to stop
them but uh devilgen is a very very
strong character right now right and
we've seen the health seats and you can
see the health is starting to get the ak
that's why the wild sand 2 hit at the
end there and the fact that arjun is now
bringing out that while standing too to
mix up with the hell sweep means that
we're gonna have an interesting set next
game
and you know knowing ak's experience
he's probably only a little bit worried
about the mix-ups from the weibos into
the while standing too you might even go
for the for the howard estate here which
is his go-to stage we'll see about that
power to stay
you called it
um
all right
potential tournament point for ak if you
can win this game
uh but i have a feeling
it's going down a final final i have a
feeling it just seems to always do that
in tekken you know
for no reason whatsoever
man this stage is sick i love it one of
the coolest stages in the game
easily
all right here we go
okay
ak follows up with the combo key charge
set up oh no he doesn't go for it anyway
yeah he wants the bigger game yeah
oh boy
oh
[Laughter]
i need to win this tournament
this is grand finals after all no duck
on a second hit but rgn does manage to
get a one one two and
slide mix-ups is rgn gonna
block any of those electric
i'm telling you the devil's waking up
[Music]
oh i love it he'll follow up on the
combo
kind of airborne double just do it again
wall
oh good low kick solid low kick and just
like that it is tournament point
for ak
god of this duck
nick the ak special let me see him key
charge set up okay takes the steel pedal
instead goes for another slide
rjn trying to be more on the offensive
side but ak's denying the denying the
opportunity good luck on the lows the
folks are coming in but rgn gets stopped
in his tracks again one two two he'll
sweep coming in i feel it coming what's
he gonna do here oh man
slidey
what the
ak to close out the tournament oh let's
go it's not over
it's not over tournament point oh
rgn still alive here showing some signs
of life but ak still is up two rounds
ahead rgn's got a health work to do hell
sweet to go
and get some more momentum a lot of
damage coming in from rgm
good interrupt there what
confirm oh airport got him this time
and just like that ak is your tekken
online challenge 2021 champion for the
philippines at east age congratulations
ak three to one there over rgn nicely
done congratulations ak
yo everybody make some noise for ak and
also rgn for making it this far
you know beating killers like maru and
jules that's not an easy feat so guys
make sure you give some praise also to
rgn this kid's got a lot to prove and
he's only getting better
amazing set man
that was fun man aka today though was
just on a different level than everybody
honestly like i've seen and commentated
multiple terms with ak in it he's had a
lot of great runs made through a lot of
top eights but the way he was playing
tonight just looked so dominant right
and he was so confident in his gameplay
through every single magic that we saw
so shout out to ak he's looking really
sharp and honestly i just i can't wait
uh for offline to come back now just
because ak's looking so good you know
just like seeing these players in
different regions of the world kind of
change over the years right it's for me
completely ak matchup it's been almost
two years i feel like you know it's been
a very long i think it literally has
been two years uh so you know players
grow in that time obviously so it's just
so crazy and so exciting to see what the
world's gonna be like when we finally
get back together for everyone offline
yeah for sure and with that being said
uh ladies and gentlemen we are gonna be
showing you guys the
the leaderboard standings in just a few
moments to see what happened uh in the
rankings right now because for sure uh
ak went up by a mile here knowing that
he won this entire tournament and joel's
maybe at the second or third place but
rgn making a name for himself here in
this tournament
yeah certainly going to be flying up the
leaderboard for rg and i believe ak was
second when we showed the leaderboards
earlier uh you gotta believe he's gonna
be first after this window right
of course these players were battling to
get to the regional finals uh which will
be coming up of course in a couple
months uh here are the standing though
you see it there aka confirmed first
place finished 370 points second place
jules with his great placing here at
third bumping him up to 250 just enough
to keep him ahead of rgn who comes in
now at 220. we got maru closing out for
it the 110 and then tomorrow clutch in
the fifth place finish alongside titan
thor with that sick bang and then t-rex
with that eddie 45 comes in at sixth
place tied actually and sidestep lance
with that lee chow lawn that we saw
earlier very fun to watch comes in to
close out our top eight for the
standings congratulations all these guys
will be seeing them in the regional
finals
and look at the massive boost it gets
you when you reach the top eight in any
of these second online challenges right
we saw earlier that sites the plants
wasn't even on this list and now here he
is with 25 points t-rex at you know 45
also so guys if you want to participate
and get to the regional finals make sure
you participate in the second online
challenge 2021 powered by astro once
again astro is the official headset and
mix amp of the second online challenge
2021 it's what we're using right now
it's great we do recommend it and man
rip
what else do you have to say about this
tournament man
no it's been great right and the one
thing i wanted to mention again about
that leaderboard it is 25 points for
eighth place right which means that's
still up for grabs you know we showed
the slide earlier that talked about the
registration deadline for the dojo
system and so if there's an online dojo
and there are enough points to be had
that you can get more than 25 points you
could still bump out and get into that
regional finals yourself and again a
huge prize pool there right lots on the
line uh for these players so if you guys
haven't already done your tournament
organizer in the region make sure you
consider throwing one of those because
that might be the difference between
these players to make it into qualified
and guys also make sure you do uh
you do follow these socials at b esports
and b and esports for twitter and
youtube as for tekken you just gotta go
ahead to twitter twitch and facebook
that is tekken as simple as it is make
sure you follow us get some updates stay
connected
a lot more tournaments are coming up so
you might want to watch the tournaments
also so
make sure you uh stay tuned for that
exactly all the bne sports guys where
you can find all of the
specific you know tournament clips
tournament highlights uh they're pretty
on top of this make sure you guys go and
drop and follow and it's also the
official place to catch all the replays
of everything right so if you guys are
missing on an event like this you want
to see the top eight jumping over to bne
esports for the youtube channel you guys
can catch the matches there
yeah for sure and
now guys
we're gonna go ahead and wrap it up
for the tekken online challenge
2021 philippines and east asia online
masters this has been kitten with me rip
again let me just say that i am so
honored to be sharing the mic with you
right now
what do you have to say same just sign
us off here of course man you know just
for everyone you know keep playing
tekken you know support the game support
your region if you guys are interested
in entering these tournaments make sure
you do so as well check out
techworldtour.com so we got some catch
around in the next one of these other
than that we are out here i'll see you
guys next time have a good one peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign